Bonjour à toutes et à
tous et merci d'avoir...
On verra. Vous allez voir, ça va
dépendre de vos réactions, à la première planche.
Non, pas celle là, la suivante.
Donc, bonjour à toutes et à tous et
merci d'avoir aménagé ce temps d'échanges.
Comme je disais juste à l'instant,
je vais commencer cette intervention.
J'ai jamais été auditionné
par votre commission, mais j'ai déjà
fréquenté un tout petit peu les ordres de
la République, enfin plus exactement ceux-ci,
puisque, j'avais eu le plaisir,
déjà, d'échanger avec la mission, sur
l'effet de serre qui avait été
constitué par l'Assemblée Nationale,
avec Jean-Yves Le Déaut et Nathalie
Kosciusko-Morizet, donc c'était la préhistoire,
des auditions sur les questions de
changement climatique à l'Assemblée Nationale.
Je vais aujourd'hui essayer de vous
montrer un certain nombre de
choses, alors, ou bien vous sautez en
l'air, à la lecture de ce qui va
suivre, et j'ai besoin de trois quarts d'heure
pour vous expliquer pourquoi c'est
logique, ou bien on part de ça comme acquis
et à ce moment j'ai juste quelques
éléments complémentaires à vous montrer.
Le premier élément de conclusion auquel
j'ai envie de vous emmener, c'est que sans
énergie, le monde moderne
existerait pas, l'énergie a façonné
la totalité de ce qui nous entoure : la hausse du pouvoir
d'achat l'urbanisation, la tertiarisation, la mondialisation,
le temps libre, les retraites,
les études longues, les 35 heures
en gros la totalité
de ce qui aujourd'hui fait
ce qu'on considère être les
acquis sociaux que nous pensons "éternels",
c'est l'énergie.
Et, il n'y a pas assez d'énergie pour que le
smicard français continue à consommer, comme il consomme.
Il s'agit pas de vous ni de moi, qui sommes dans les
catégories supérieures, il s'agit bien du smicard français
qui n'aura pas la
possibilité et, ça a déjà commencé,
de continuer à consommer, comme il
consomme, et toute la question est de
savoir : comment est-ce que ce genre de situation se
gère sans que ça dégénère en instabilité sociale très forte?
La deuxième chose, que je souhaite vous
dire, c'est, qu'en première approximation,,
j'ai de très belles courbes pour le montrer, le
PIB mondial ne dépend que de l'énergie disponible.
Dit autrement, si l'énergie
disponible se met à être contrainte,
et il s'agit pas de
prix, il s'agit de volume,
alors que le PIB se met a être
contraint, et, en fait, c'est très
exactement la raison pour laquelle
Monsieur Sarkozy s'est trompé quand il
a annoncé la hausse du pouvoir d'achat,
en 2007, et Monsieur Hollande s'est trompé
quand il a annoncé le retour de la croissance
en 2012, ils ont, tous les deux, fait la même erreur
ils ont pensé que leur
volonté était plus forte que la
physique malheureusement la physique
est plus forte que leur volonté et donc il
n'y aura plus de croissance
à partir de maintenant en Europe
en règle générale on sera dans un
monde sans croissance une année sur deux
la récession, une
année sur deux un petit rebond
c'est tout simplement lié au fait que
l'approvisionnement énergétique en Europe est déjà contraint
et je commence par la conclusion après vous
verrez si vous avez besoin des explications intermédiaires
en Europe à cause des
contraintes qui pèsent dès à présent sur
l'approvisionnement en gaz et en pétrole
qui représente environ les deux
tiers de l'énergie consommés en Europe
oui la présentation pourra
circuler il n'y a pas de problème
et vous savez on retient 90 % de ce
qu'on écrit et 10% de ce qu'on entends
Il y a, dès à présent, en Europe, une contrainte
d'approvisionnement qui fait, j'insiste, que la croissance perpétuelle ne reviendra plus.
Alors, on peut trouver ça,
triste, désagréable, "je ne sais pas quoi".
Mon sentiment c'est, que tout
plan fait pour l'avenir qui présuppose,
que l'on va financer, n'importe quoi,
avec les surplus d'une croissance retrouvée :
Ce plan fera faillite.
C'est assez simple.
À partir de maintenant, il faut faire
les plans pour l'avenir, sans croissance.
Voilà, donc ça, je viens de dire.
De ce fait, le temps joue contre nous.
Et de ce fait, il ya un effet d'éviction absolument
majeur, dans le fait de financer des trucs qui ne servent à rien.
Dit autrement : tout truc qui sert à rien engendre un
effet d'éviction sur les trucs qui pourrait servir à quelque chose.
Et, pour aller
directement aux fruits de ma pensée,
si on dépense des dizaines de
milliards en panneaux photovoltaïques, et ben ces
dizaines de milliards ne sont
plus disponibles pour faire des trucs qui
servent vraiment à quelque chose,
étant donné que, les panneaux photovoltaïques
portent sur des
pouillèmes, dans la situation actuelle,
on ne peut pas compter, sur la
limitation de l'énergie fossile disponible.
Donc dit autrement on ne peut plus
habiller Paul, sans déshabiller Jacques.
Voilà, c'est la
caractéristique d'un univers sans croissance.
On est dans une mauvaise
situation, en termes d'échelle de temps,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a trop d'énergie
fossile sur cette terre, pour compter sur
sa limitation, pour sauver le climat,
mais il y en a déjà plus assez, pour compter sur
son abondance, pour faire
redémarrer l'économie européenne.
Je peux répéter, si vous voulez ?
Dit autrement, il va falloir, que l'Europe trouve le moyen, avec une économie
sans croissance, d'inciter les gens qui ont plein de charbon, à ne pas taper dedans.
Voilà, je vous rappelle que nos voisins allemands
ont décidé de faire exactement l'inverse, pour le moment.
Et enfin, la dernière chose, le dernier élément de
conclusion c'est que bien évidemment la hiérarchie des nuisances,
ou la hiérarchie des mérites, valable dans
le monde infini, n'est pas celle qui est valable
dans un monde fini, puisque l'ordre respectif des
contraintes, que l'on doit prendre en compte, change complètement.
Entre autres conclusions, ça
implique aussi que les modèles macroéconomiques
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui qui
sont asservis qui bouclent par les prix
et qui présuppose des élasticités
entre les prix et les volumes qui sont à peu
près constantes sont devenues
grossièrement inopérants, c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a pas entre guillemets
vu venir la crise de 2007 qu'on pourrait très
bien voir venir si on se concentre
sur les volumes et notamment les volumes
d'énergie et qu'on ne voit
pas venir si on regarde les prix
et l'une des choses que je
vous montrerai si j'en ai le temps
Aujourd'hui, par exemple sur le pétrole, il n'y a plus d'élasticité prix/volume,
c'est-à-dire que le prix du pétrole ne donne pas la quantité de pétrole : il donne le prix.
Or, ce qui compte pour l'économie,
c'est la quantité, ce n'est pas le prix.
Donc, voilà les quelques conclusions que je
vous propose. Alors, maintenant, il y a deux options :
c'est comme les films où vous pouvez choisir la fin : ou bien on
part de ces choses-là, j'ai plus rien à vous montrer et on discute.
Ou bien, ça demande quand même quelques
explications et, à ce moment, je vous les fournis.
Alors, on va continuer.
Et on va commencer par des choses
que vous avez sûrement entendu qui sont
totalement contradictoires avec ce que je viens de
raconter : la première chose que vous avez entendu, qui est vraie
Ce n'est pas la peine de s'occuper du pétrole, parce qu'il ya
de moins en moins de pétrole, dans le PIB, c'est tout à fait vrai.
Si vous regardez la quantité de
pétrole par euros de PIB elle décroît.
La deuxième chose que vous pourriez
dire c'est que, hormis cas particulier
de précarité, c'est pas la peine de
s'occuper du prix de l'énergie puisque
la part de l'énergie, dans le budget
des ménages, décroît, depuis 35 ans à 40 ans.
L'énergie vaut, aujourd'hui, moins lourd, dans le
budget des ménages, qu'avant le premier choc pétrolier.
Donc, on pourrait très bien dire que, mis à part
quelques personnes qui rouspètent un peu, ce n'est pas un problème.
On pourrait dire aussi qu'il y a de plus en plus de
pétrole de gaz et de charbon extractible, j'y reviendrai,
vous l'avez sûrement entendu, voilà, c'est très récent, on doit
s'occuper du climat en 2015, donc d'ici là, ce n'est pas la peine de s'exciter.
Un autre truc, que vous avez aussi entendu, c'est que le
progrès technique et le génie humain résoudront tous les problèmes,
du reste, avec des politiques
courageuses, on peut faire exactement ce
qu'on veut c'est une affaire de volonté politique, et moi, je
ne suis pas complètement sûr, que la physique soit d'accord avec ça.
On va revenir à la physique, pour le début de cette intervention, pour
rappeler quelque chose que certains, dans cette salle, connaissent probablement,
Je suis désolé, ce que je vais
dire, maintenant, est probablement
des redites pour certains, et des
découvertes pour d'autres, je ne sais pas faire autrement,
parce que le niveau de connaissances préalables
sur le sujet je vais traiter est devenu très hétérogène
donc c'est très difficile de faire
un truc qui convienne à tout le monde
Donc, je vais simplement rappeler que l'énergie, par définition en physique, caractérise le changement
d'état d'un système l'énergie, avant d'être des kilowattheures, sur une facture, c'est une grandeur physique.
Et c'est la grandeur physique qui
caractérise le changement d'état d'un système.
Donc elle obéit à des
lois, qui sont des vrais lois.
Dit autrement, qui ne
souffrent pas d'exception.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que l'énergie caractérise le changement d'état
d'un système ? ça veut dire que dès que le monde change, de l'énergie intervient.
Vous pouvez le voir dans un certain nombre de
modifications qui sont courantes autour de vous.
Par exemple : un changement de
température fait intervenir de l'énergie
un changement de vitesse fait
intervenir de l'énergie, dit autrement,
vous ne pouvez pas faire changer un objet
de vitesse, sans que de l'énergie entre en jeu,
vous ne pouvez pas faire changer la
forme d'un objet sans que de l'énergie
entre en jeu, vous ne pouvez pas modifier une
composition chimique sans que de l'énergie entre en jeu,
vous ne pouvez pas déplacer un
corps dans un champ avec lequel il interagit
sans que de l'énergie entre en jeu,
vous ne pouvez pas changer une composition
atomique sans que l'énergie
entre en jeu, et vous ne pouvez pas faire
interagir de la matière et du rayonnement, alors là je
vous ai montré la version agréable, à partir du 1er juillet,
y'a une version plus courante, de tous
les jours, c'est les fours à micro-ondes,
à chaque fois de l'énergie entre en jeu.
Dit autrement, où l'économiste va mesurer la transformation avec des euros de valeur ajoutée, du
moins, quand il s'agit d'une activité économique des hommes, le physicien verra des kilowattheures.
Pas de transformation
sans kilowattheures, jamais.
Du coup, pas d'énergie propre, puisque l'énergie s'est transformée et la
transformation ne peut pas être propre, la propreté c'est laisser les choses en l'état.
L'énergie, c'est fait pour ne pas laisser les
choses en l'état, donc l'énergie propre n'existe pas.
Ce qui peut exister, c'est de
l'énergie utilisée, dans des quantités telle, que
les avantages
surpassent les inconvénients, ça oui,
mais l'énergie propre n'existe pas.
Pas plus verte, que rose, que
violette à paillettes, du reste.
Ce que je vous ai dit, tout à l'heure, sur le
fait que l'énergie a structuré notre monde moderne
réside en totalité, dans le petit calcul
d'ordre de grandeur, que je vais vous montrer maintenant
Si on suppose qu'on transpose l'hémicycle à Chamonix, et que vous
montez, tous les matins, sur le Mont-Blanc, pour vous mettre en appétit,
tous les matins, ce n'est pas facile, vous
allez voir, ça ne fait pas beaucoup d'énergie.
et bien en montant sur le Mont-Blanc
Si, je l'ai fait il y a longtemps.
En montant, sur le Mont-Blanc, et bien, l'énergie mécanique que vous
allez restituer, avec vos jambes, est de l'ordre d'un demi kilowattheure.
Vous voyez ce qu'un être humain peut fournir, avec ses
muscles, en une journée de transpiration, assez significative,
c'est de l'ordre d'un demi kilowattheure d'énergie
mécanique. Si vous faites intervenir vos bras vous êtes à 10 fois moins.
Pour le 10 fois moins, c'est de l'ordre de 5 mètres cubes de terre remonté
d'un mètre vous pouvez essayer, ça fait un bel exercice, et de belles ampoules.
Dit autrement, quelqu'un de très bien entraîné, qui est capable de
faire ce genre de plaisanterie, un jour sur deux et bien, à la fin d'année,
il aura été capable de fournir avec ses muscles de l'ordre de
100 kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique, donc retenez cette équivalence,
un être humain égal 100 kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique fournie, en un an, maximum, maximorum.
Raisonnons un tout petit peu économie, si vous
prenez pour ça quelqu'un qui est payé au smic en France
vous allez payer, votre kilowattheure d'énergie
mécanique, quelques centaines à quelques milliers d'euros.
Avant l'avènement de l'énergie fossile, la capacité de transformation du monde des hommes valait, entre
guillemets, des centaines ou des milliers de fois plus cher, que ce que les machines nous permettent de faire aujourd'hui.
Exactement.
Alors prenons un esclave ce qui n'est pas
politiquement correct, mais ce qui a été un fait,
C'est moins cher, mais c'est
quand même plus cher que l'énergie.
Il faut le nourrir, il faut l'empêcher de mourir, il faut
l'acheter, etc... rien que ça, ça vous coûte quelques euros par jour.
Et le salariat découle de l'énergie abondante. Sans énergie
abondante, on aura, de nouveau, des tensions sociales très fortes.
Dans un litre d'essence, vous avez, de l'ordre de, 10 kilowattheures d'énergie ce qui veut dire que, ça
vous permet d'avoir de l'énergie mécanique, pour 1000 à 10000 fois moins cher, que le coût du travail, en Occident.
Tout réside là dedans : la hausse du pouvoir d'achat, l'industrialisation, etc,
etc et y compris aussi la tertiarisation des emplois, ce que je vais vous montrer après.
Voilà, comment a évolué la quantité d'énergie consommée par
personne, à la surface de la planète, depuis un siècle et demi.
Vous voyez que, dans 1860, le terrien ordinaire avait à peu près
1.500 kilowattheures d'énergie par an, c'était surtout l'énergie thermique,
en Europe, charbon et
bois, donc ça lui servait à
chauffer un peu au début, de
la métallurgie, un peu au début,
du transport : bateau à vapeur, train.
Et puis, au fil du temps, cette quantité d'énergie est progressivement
montée, à 20.000 kilowattheures par personne et par an, extraite de l'environnement,
dans lequel vous voyez : a)
que le charbon n'a jamais décru
le charbon reste une énergie très
consommée par personne dans le monde et
on verra après pourquoi aucune énergie n'en a
cannibalisé une autre de manière massive, aucune.
b) le pétrole est venu se rajouter sur le
charbon, le gaz sur le pétrole et le charbon etc...
et ce qui excite tant nos amis journalistes, vous savez l'éolien, le biogaz, le
photovoltaïque, la géothermie, etc... c'est le petit machin en bleu que vous avez tout en haut.
Donc, pour le
moment, on parle de trombones.
Non, non, parce que là, c'est très partagé cette affaire-là, c'est assez
indépendant de la couleur politique, on parle d'un sujet sérieux, s'il vous plaît donc.
quelques pourcents
de décroissance par an...
bah le nucléaire
c'est un plus gros machin
quelques pourcents de décroissance...
et pour répondre directement à
cette question si vous pensez que ça ça
jouera jamais aucun rôle alors les
nombres font que ça en fera encore moins
quelques pourcents
de décroissance par an...
s'il vous plaît
l'énergie c'est des règles de trois
donc quelques pourcents de décroissance de fossiles par an auront
énormément de mal à être compensés par la croissance des "énergies nouvelles".
Enormément.
c'est une affaire de règle de trois
pourquoi est-ce que le
charbon n'a jamais décrû dans le monde?
tout simplement parce que les deux
tiers du charbon mondial aujourd'hui servent
à produire de l'électricité et vous
verrez un peu plus tard que le premier
mode de production
d'électricité dans le monde c'est le charbon
il faut savoir qu'une
centrale électrique 85 % d'électricité
mondiale est faite en faisant bouillir de l'eau donc
c'est des bouilloires compliquées, les centrales électriques
et on peut faire la chaleur
soit avec du charbon soit avec du gaz
soit avec du pétrole soit avec de l'uranium
à chaque fois vous faites de la chaleur
faites bouillir de l'eau faites de la vapeur
vous attaquez une turbine
et dans tous les cas de figure
vous avez besoin d'une source froide
puisque vous avez une
machine de Carnot chaque fois
donc les deux tiers du charbon
mondial c'est de l'électricité le pétrole c'est
l'énergie des transports et donc ce
n'est pas le même usage que l'électricité
ce que vous voyez ici et retenez ce
pourcentage parce que ça expliquera pourquoi
mon lien énergie et PIB et pourquoi
partir de maintenant il n'y aura plus de croissance
+2,5% sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne pendant plus d'un siècle
pendant lequel nous avons
structuré les infrastructures les villes changé
l'agriculture, fait l'industrie, bâti
les systèmes sociaux qui vont dessus, etc...
+2,5% par an
depuis 1980 : "cacahuètes"
et en fait l'essentiel de la
hausse, c'est charbon et c'est la Chine
si j'enlève le charbon en
Chine pour le reste du monde c'est zéro
donc depuis 1980
hormis la Chine
l'approvisionnement énergétique par personne n'augmente
plus et en fait ce qu'on a pas vu
parce qu'on ne regarde que les prix c'est que
les chocs pétroliers qu'on
marqué une rupture de pente massive
sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique par personne
qui a commencé a totalement
chambouler le système économique mondial
en faisant apparaître le chômage, l'endettement, et un
certain nombre de problème qui n'existait pas avant 1974.
C'est pas une affaire de prix,
vous allez voir après,
c'est une affaire de volume.
il n'en reste pas moins qu'aujourd'hui
chaque terrien dispose de
l'équivalent de 200 esclaves par personne
c'est ça que nous a procuré
l'énergie abondante et à bas prix
dit autrement si nous n'avions pas
les énergies fossiles on devrait avoir 200
planètes Terre
supplémentaires dans le système solaire
où sur chacune de ces planètes, 7
milliards de bonshommes pédaleraient
comme des fous toute la journée
et ça nous permettrait
à nous, Térriens, de vivre
comme nous vivons aujourd'hui
donc les Terriens
d'aujourd'hui sont assez comparables
aux citoyens de l'Ancienne Grèce vous savez il y en
avait un tout petit nombre c'est cela dont on se souvient,
avec une armée de paysans qui
était en train... d'esclaves et de
paysans qui étaient en train de trimer pour eux
et qui n'avaient pas du tout les droits électifs etc...
voilà c'est exactement pareil
en fait la raison pour laquelle on
peut se consacrer aux affaires publiques
avoir le droit de vote etc c'est parce
que l'énergie a remplacé la force de nos muscles
et on n'est pas obligé passer
notre journée à faire pousser des patates
alors par-dessus ça on a évidemment
eu une croissance démographique très forte
au moment où l'humanité se sédentarise
on est à peu près quelques millions
donc la moitié de la
population francilienne
au moment où naît la civilisation industrielle
: un demi-milliard et aujourd'hui en deux siècles
huit générations
rien du tout à l'échelle de
l'histoire humaine huit générations
quatre fois passé de
grand parents à petits-enfants
eh bien, on est passé à 7
milliards et ça continue d'augmenter
et du coup bien évidemment la
consommation globale d'énergie à explosé
80 % de cette consommation sur Terre
est le fait de combustibles fossiles c'est
à dire que c'est du
reste de vies anciennes
fougères du carbonifère pour
le charbon 300 millions d'années
algues et plancton
pour le gaz et le pétrole
même l'électricité est massivement fossiles
vous avez ici la production électrique mondiale
en 1973 et en 2007 exprimées en
milliards de kilowattheure électrique
donc en térawattheures =
milliards de kilowattheures
alors pour mémoire la
production française aujourd'hui c'est 550
térawattheures la consommation
électrique mondiale en 1945 c'était 600
donc l'électricité c'est vraiment le
fait de la deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
c'est une énergie
qui n'existait pas avant
ce que vous voyez c'est qu'en 1973
les combustibles fossiles font les trois
quarts de la production électrique
en 2007 ils en font les deux tiers
ce qui a le plus augmenté dans le
monde depuis c'est le charbon et de très loin
la Chine installe aujourd'hui
une tranche à charbon par semaine
une tranche à charbon par semaine ça
fait un peu moins de pagination dans le
journal français que les
quelques fois où il achètent un EPR
une tranche à
charbon par semaine en Chine
les capacités installées
aujourd'hui dans le monde les premières d'entre
elles c'est du charbon
entre 150 et 200 gigawatts de
centrales à charbon en construction en ce moment
alors laquelle je vous parle
sachant que les
capacités installées en France
sont de l'ordre de 100 tous
modes de productions confondus
vous voyez que derrière
celle plus augmenté c'est gaz
et seulement derrière vous avez
l'hydroélectricité et le nucléaire
alors il y a aussi les énergies
renouvelables dans le monde je vous le disais
la première d'entre-elle alors retenez une
règle du pouce qui marche très bien c'est que
l'importance des énergies
renouvelables dans le monde est inversement
proportionnelle à leur
pagination dans le journal français
ça marche très très bien
10%
je vous parle du journal français
10% de l'énergie
mondiale provient du bois
qui n'est en fait dès à présent
plus totalement renouvelable puisqu'une
partie du bois-énergie consommé
dans le monde correspond à de la recherche
de bois de feu autour des villes
africaines et ça ça engendre de la déforestation
ensuite arrive
l'hydroélectricité qui représente aujourd'hui
l'essentiel des capacités d'énergie renouvelable
en construction dans le monde, loin devant l'éolien
et ensuite arrive l'éolien
qui là avec la convention la plus
favorable que je puisse
utiliser c'est-à-dire l'équivalent primaire
alors vous donne un peu
moins de 1% de l'énergie mondiale
les agrocarburants c'est 0,4%
retenez pour mémoire qu'avec cette unité le
pétrole ça fait 4
milles (millions de TEP)
donc dans le même temps que le monde
consomme 4 mille millions de tonnes de vrai pétrole
on fait 60 millions
de tonnes d'agrocarburants
1,5% des carburants mondiaux et pour ça
les américains utilisent déjà 40% de leur maïs
c'est à dire la même chose que ce qu'ils donnent aux animaux
40 % du maïs américain va dans
l'alimentation animale 40% dans les agrocarburants
en Allemagne, vous avez déjà des producteurs de maïs
qui mettent leurs maïs directement dans les méthaniseurs,
donc ça ne passe plus
par la case alimentation
alors pour favoriser
la production de biogaz
qui ensuite favorisera à l'électricité
donc l'utilisation de la biomasse on
y reviendra après au moment des questions
j'imagine à des fins énergétiques c'est un
truc qui doit se regarder de manière un peu précise
on peut pas dire *clic*
"biomasse solution miracle"
et enfin le photovoltaïque
aujourd'hui ça fait 0,1% de la production
énergétique
mondiale et même pas électrique
c'est toujours pareil mon problème
de pourcentage et de règle de trois à
quelle vitesse est-ce
que ce truc-là doit croître
pour compenser de manière
significative un déclin de 2 ou 3% sur un truc qui
fait un tiers de
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial ?
c'est juste un
problème de règle de trois!
voilà ici l'approvisionnement
alors non pas primaire c'est-à-dire non pas
l'énergie qu'on retire de
l'environnement il faut savoir un truc
avec l'énergie c'est que
à cause d'une loi physique
qui s'appelle la loi de conservation
tout ce que les hommes peuvent faire c'est
d'extraire de l'environnement une énergie qui s'y trouve déjà
le terme "production
d'énergie" est un terme impropre
c'est une violation de la physique
tout ce que les hommes savent faire c'est
extraire de l'environnement une énergie qui s'y trouve déjà
alors qu'est-ce qu'on trouve
dans l'environnement des trucs qui brûle
des noyaux
d'uranium qui se casse en deux
de l'eau qui tombe du vent qui
souffle du rayonnement qui arrive
on ne trouve pas d'électricité
du moins tant qu'on ne sait pas
brancher les cafetières sur les éclairs d'orage
on ne trouve pas d'hydrogène pas natifs
il y en a plein dans l'eau mais il faut
plein d'énergie pour le dissocier de l'oxygène
donc tout ce que vous trouvez dans
l'environnement c'est de l'énergie dite
primaire et vous allez
l'extraire la transformer avec un système
énergétique et en faire de
l'énergie finale c'est celle qu'on utilise nous
carburant qui rentre dans les voitures,
l'électricité qui alimente les cafetières, etc...
vous avez ici la répartition de
l'énergie finale consommée en france
en milliards de kilowattheures
par secteur et par énergie finale
tout ce qui est cerclé en
bleu, c'est des combustibles fossiles
donc voyez la france n'est pas un
pays tout nucléaire c'est un pays avant tout
tout fossiles si on regarde l'énergie
finale exactement comme nos voisins européens
l'électricité est
essentiellement tout nucléaire
l'électricité : oui
l'énergie : non
alors les journalistes ont souvent
la confusion entre les deux parce qu'on
aime bien parler de ce qu'on voit et
en France, ce qu'on voit c'est des centrales
électriques, on ne voit pas de puits
de pétrole, on ne voit pas de puits de gaz,
essentiellement on
voit quelques barrages,
donc on parle de ce qu'on voit
mais l'essentiel de l'énergie
que nous utilisons vient d'ailleurs
et donc le journaliste
français n'est pas focalisé dessus
en ce qui concerne l'électricité
retenez aussi quelque chose qui est
important pour les politiques
publiques c'est que l'essentiel de l'utilisation
d'électricité n'est
pas un usage thermique
c'est un usage du spécifique
c'est à dire que ça alimente des tas
d'appareils qui ne sert pas à produire de la chaleur :
les frigos, des pompes, des
lave-linges, des lave-vaisselles, des ascenseurs etc...
et économiser de
l'énergie dans ses usages-là
c'est quelque chose qui est plus
compliqué que d'en économiser dans la chaleur
on a aussi des énergies
renouvelables en France dont la hiérarchie est très
exactement celle qu'on a dans le
monde arrive en premier le bois puis en
deuxième l'hydroélectricité
et puis ensuite des tas de bricoles
et vous avez ici l'éolien et qui fait
surtout, hors erreur de ma part, 5% de 7%
et pour le photovoltaïque,
qui est là, qui fait 1% de 7%
revenons au volumes
vous avez ici le taux de croissance de la
consommation énergétique mondiale depuis 1945
je vous l'ai séparé en deux morceaux
entre 1945 et premier choc
pétrolier vous voyez que l'énergie mondiale
augmente en moyenne sur la période de 5%
et là vous avez l'augmentation
moyenne sur la période après le choc
pétrolier et vous voyez ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure la descente très forte
de ce taux de croissance et si vous faites
une courbe de tendance sur ce taux de croissance
voyez quelle est négative
donc pour ceux à qui ça dit quelque chose la
dérivée seconde est négative et donc il suffit d'attendre et
ce taux de croissance deviendra nul
puis négatif
un taux de croissance
négatif s'appelle un diminution
avant de vous dire quelle conclusion
ça m'inspire revenons à la manière dont
l'énergie à structuré les
métiers parce que ça c'est pareil l'un
des trucs qui compte en
démocratie c'est d'avoir un emploi
les grands maîtres penseurs le
disaient déjà quasiment deux siècles
l'énergie a totalement
déplacé la structure des métiers
vous avez ici l'évolution de
l'emploi en France depuis deux siècles
vous voyez il y a deux siècles
le Français ordinaire était paysan
tout le monde avait comme fonction
productive première de se nourrir lui
+ nourrir 0,5 personnes pardon
qui n'étaient pas dans les champs
les deux tiers de la population
active dans les champs ça veut dire que, pour
moi, il y a que chaque personne se
nourrit lui + 0,5 personne qui n'y est pas
Arrive l'énergie. L'énergie permet
de fabriquer des machines qui vont rendre
service aux paysans des
charrues plus efficaces etc...
ça permet de fabriquer des
moissonneuses batteuses ça permet
d'augmenter les rendements, puis un jour, on va
mettre les machines directement dans les champs après-guerre
ça s'appelle des tracteurs, un
tracteur c'est 1.000 paires de jambes
un tracteur de 100 chevaux c'est à peu
près 1000 paires de jambes en puissance développée
et donc un paysan maintenant il
se nourrit plus 50 autres personnes
alors qu'il nourrissait, avant,
lui + 0,5 personnes et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui lui + 50 personnes
ces 50 autres personnes
peuvent se mettre à faire autre chose
grâce à l'énergie qui permet de
transformer des tas d'autres ressources
que nous trouvons dans
l'environnement des minerais du bois
des sols etc... et on va donc se
mettre à développer l'industrie qui
n'est rien d'autre que la
transformation de ressources naturelles
tous les objets que vous avez dans cette
salle c'est des ressources transformées, tous
il n'y a pas un
qui échappe à cette règle
donc l'industrie prend des
ressources gratuites dans notre système économique
et les transforme
pour en faire autre chose
arrive le choc pétrolier et à ce moment
le flux global d'énergies
et ce que je suis en train de vous décrire là, s'est
reproduit dans tous les pays occidentaux au même moment
d'accord c'est donc que
c'est par l'incurie du politique
le pays A qui fait que la
situation se présente comme elle se présente
c'est vraiment la fait physique global
dans tous les pays à ce
moment la productivité par personne
se met à aller plus vite que le
flux global contraint par l'énergie
globale et à ce moment-là la
part de l'emploi industriel baisse
avec soit-dit en passant un subtilité
de nomenclature parce que si vous prenez un
ouvrier dans une usine automobile
il est dans l'industrie si vous prenez un
garagiste sous un
pont-levant réparant une voiture qui fait
physiquement exactement les mêmes
gestes vous allez le mettre dans les services
aujourd'hui
la question de savoir qu'est-ce qui est de
l'industrie et qu'est-ce qui est des services est
devenue une question ça peut vous paraître
trivial mais qui est en fait une vraie question
et quand vous parlez à monsieur Pépy qui
vous dit "Moi, je suis un industriel" et quand
vous regardez ce que c'est qu'un
train un atelier de maintenance il a raison
l'INSEE le met dans les services
quand mon charcutier fait son
boudin, excellent au demeurant, chez lui il est
dans les services, quand un ouvrier de chez Doux,
découpe des poulets dans une usine il est dans l'industrie
discuter de la pertinence de cette
nomenclature pour savoir ce qu'on doit faire plus tard
fin de la parenthèse
donc toujours est-il
qu'avec la nomenclature de l'INSEE
vous voyez que la part de l'emploi
dans l'industrie se met à baisser mais le
flux industriels continue d'augmenter il
a jamais été aussi important qu'aujourd'hui
et donc les services où la
productivité est moindre peuvent continuer
d'augmenter derrière. C'est quoi?
c'est les services c'est le commerce c'est
la banque et puis c'est le
transport etc... mais on voit
également apparaître nouvelle
catégorie qui n'existait pas avant 1974
qui s'appellent les chômeurs
les chômeurs
c'est une manière
particulière dans le système physique
avec laquelle le
système physique pardon gère
le fait que la productivité globale
du travail ne puisse plus augmenter aussi
vite qu'avant
puisque la productivité du
travail c'est l'énergie qu'on a
donc ça ne peut plus augmenter aussi vite
qu'avant et à ce moment on voit l'apparition de chômeurs
avant 1974, il y a un siècle il
fallait plutôt passer des lois pour éviter que
les femmes les enfants et les
nourrissons travaillent 24h sur 24
donc l'élément limitant
avant 1974 c'était le travail
depuis 1974 l'élément limitant
n'est plus le travail, c'est l'énergie
vous allez le voir
après, c'est l'énergie
voilà un instantané de ce que je vous ai
raconté pour la France et là c'est pour le monde
donc vous avez ici pour l'ensemble
des pays du monde je suis désolé je n'ai pas
mis les étiquettes à côté des points
la consommation d'énergie par
personne en fonction de la fraction de l'emploi
dans l'agriculture ou plus exactement
la faction de l'emploi dans l'agriculture en
fonction l'énergie consommée par
personne et ce que vous voyez c'est que
aujourd'hui dans le monde
plus on a de l'énergie par
personne et moins vous avez d'emplois dans
l'agriculture c'est très exactement ce que
je vous ai montré en dynamique tout à l'heure
ces gens vont à ce moment faire des
emplois industriels et services dans les villes
donc l'organisation
c'est l'énergie abondante
l'urbanisation c'est l'énergie
abondante le fait que la ville puisse être
un système socio-économique stable
en univers énergétique très contraint
avec 80% de la
population dedans, ce n'est pas sûr
c'est pas sûr du tout
et voilà un autre truc qui devrait
un peu vous perturber parce que moi ça m'a
perturbé la
première fois que j'ai fait ça
vous avez ici les
émissions de CO2 par personne
en fonction de la part
de l'emploi dans les services
vous savez on dit toujours quand
on met des services on dématérialise...
c'est l'exact inverse qu'on voit
plus vous avez de
service dans l'économie en gros
et plus vous avez d'énergie
fossile consommée par personne
alors c'est très perturbant
en fait c'est très logique
vous pouvez avoir tout le monde
dans les services à partir du moment où la
totalité de nos fonctions
productives sont assurés par des machines qui
consomment de l'énergie
et à ce moment les services qui
consiste à gérer ces flux physiques
Qu'est ce que c'est? Les services ça permet
de gérer de l'information, gérer des flux physiques
eh bien vous pouvez mettre à peu
près toute la population active dedans
mon sentiment ? il y a des
études qui commencèrent à illustrer ça
c'est que dans un monde contraint
sur l'énergie la part du travail manuel
va augmenter et non pas baisser
et la part des services
va baisser et non augmenter
à la subtilité près que je vous
exposais tout à l'heure sur savoir ce qui était de
l'industrie et des services
alors je crois vous avez aussi en
charge l'aménagement du territoire voilà
comment l'énergie abondante déformé
l'occupation du territoire
plus besoin de personnes dans les
campagnes on a mis les tracteurs tout le monde en ville
et on peut conserver la fonction
d'échanges des villes parce que ça sert à
ça, ça sert une fonction d'échanges
en étalant les banlieues puisque l'énergie abondante permet
de garder des flux en volumes et en délais extrêmement performants
avec des gens de plus en plus éloignés
le temps de déplacement peut
être conservé constant avec des
voitures pour tous alors que quand
il fallait marcher on faisait tous les
commerces sur le Pont-Neuf et
c'est comme ça que c'était le plus efficace
vous voyez que l'évolution que je vous
montre ici a été vécu par tous les pays occidentaux
ce n'est pas le propre de la
France que je suis en train de vous raconter
la concentration urbaine et l'étalement
urbain c'est le fait de tous les pays occidentaux
alors quand on a démarré les villes
avant l'énergie abondante les cœurs de
ville sont denses quand on a
démarré Atlanta déjà à l'époque de
l'énergie abondante il
n'y a pas de cœur de ville
si vous allez à Atlanta et que vous
demandez au portier de l'hôtel où se trouve le
centre-ville il rigole
parce qu'il sait pas où c'est
y'a pas de centre-ville ça n'existe pas
revoici maintenant l'évolution
de l'énergie consommée dans le monde
depuis 1965 mais cette fois-ci
je vous montre ça sous un autre angle
vous avez en bleu les pays de l'OCDE
et vous voyez que les
pays de l'OCDE sont déjà
en approvisionnement décroissant
et ça commence à décroître
et ici vous avez les pays dits émergents
chez qui contraire
l'approvisionnement continue à croître et au sein de ses
pays émergents vous avez la Chine
où l'approvisionnement croît
extrêmement fort maintenant regardons
l'évolution du PIB de ces pays
voilà le PIB en dollars constants
des pays de l'OCDE depuis 1960
et vous voyez qu'on vit depuis
2007 et vous verrez
après pourquoi cause du pétrole
un épisode inédit
il n'y a plus de croissance
alors je ne sais pas combien de temps
ça va durer je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
je pense que ça va durer un
certain temps il n'y en a plus
à cause de raisons énergétiques
par contre chez les hôtes là ça continue
alors voilà la France c'est pareil
plus de croissance en monnaie constante et
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
Sarkozy a promis un truc qu'il ne pouvait pas
tenir pour des raisons physiques et
Hollande a promis un truc qu'il ne pourra pas
tenir pour des raisons physiques
mais ils font tous la même
erreur dans tous les pays dans toutes les
démocratie... alors voilà le
système économique sur lequel on
raisonne pour promettre la
croissance du pouvoir d'achat
c'est le système
économique vous avez appris à l'école
le super quelque chose change en
fonction du contexte je vous précise que
je n'ai rien contre M.
Draghi ni contre M. Ayrault
à titre personnel.. donc voilà
comment s'organise le système économique te
que nous l'apprenons à l'école
vous avez deux facteurs de production le
capital et travail et donc si la
production n'est pas assez élevé pour
payer les retraites et
assurer et boucher le trou de la sécu
eh bien on dit qu'on va baisser
les charges sur le travail + de travail
et on dit qu'on va baisser
le coût du capital + de crédit etc
ça marche pas
en ce moment le
capital est à coût négatif
l'Allemagne emprunte à coût négatif et du
travail on en a "à ne plus savoir qu'en faire"
on a plein de chômeurs
pourtant le PIB n'augmente pas
donc c'est que ça marche pas comme ça
en fait ça marche de la
manière suivante physiquement
l'économie n'est qu'une énorme machine à
transformer des ressources naturelles gratuites
et le capital la formation de capital
plus exactement est une boucle interne au système
l'immeuble dans lequel nous sommes qui est un élément
capital ça n'est rien d'autre que des ressources et du travail passé
c'est juste ça
le brevet qu'un industriel déposera aujourd'hui ça
n'est rien d'autre que des ressources et du travail passé
la marque qu'entreprise achètera peut-être aujourd'hui
c'est rien d'autre que des ressources et du travail passé
donc le capital c'est des ressources
et du travail passé et l'économie qu'une
énorme machine à transformer les
ressources la transformation je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est de l'énergie
cet énergie est fourni par 1 pour nos
muscles par 200 pour l'énergie extracorporelle
alors une fois vous
avez ce schéma en tête
ce que je voulais raconter devient logique si
vous avez un goulet d'étranglement sur l'énergie
quel que soit le prix de l'énergie par ailleurs si vous avez moins de
kilowattheures vous aurez moins de PIB quelque soit le prix de l'énergie
une illustration idiote
si demain matin je divise
l'approvisionnement pétrolier de la France par deux
c'est caricatural mais
c'est pour faire bien comprendre
je peux garantir aux camionneurs
que le litre de gazole à 0,80 euros
s'ils ont deux fois moins la
machine économique française se grippe.
c'est pas une affaire de prix
c'est une affaire de quantité
le prix répond aux quantités tant
qu'il n'y a pas de problème sur les quantités.
Quand il y a des problèmes sur
les quantités le système s'organise plus
comme ça donc si vous surveillez
le prix vous n'aurez pas la quantité
si vous avez un problème sur les
ressources, vous aurez aussi un impact sur la
production je vais prendre un exemple
idiot que je prends souvent qui est la pêche
dans la pêche le capital c'est
votre bateau, le travail c'est votre marin
ce que vous pêchez, c'est des poissons.
L'énergie c'est le gazole que vous mettez dans votre
bateau et le PIB, c'est la valeur des poissons pêchés.
Donc tant que le poisson est dans la mer, sa valeur dans
sa contribution dans le dans le PIB c'est zéro, nul d'accord?
c'est 15 milliards d'années
d'évolution qui a fait le patrimoine génétique des
poissons et qui a fait l'océan et
qui permet aux poissons d'arriver tout
seuls dans la mer
sans qu'on lui demande rien
gratuit, ça, gratos.
pas un centime.
vous pêchez le poisson donc il vous faut
un bateau, du diesel, un marin et un poisson
si vous avez plus de diesel
je ne sais pas si il y a un ancien député du
Guilvinec ici? faire avancer le chalutier du Guilvinec
à la rame, c'est compliqué
plus de diesel, plus
de poissons, plus de PIB
donc vous aurez vos marins, votre travail,
vous aurez votre capital : le bateau mais pas de PIB.
si vous avez votre marin votre
diesel votre bateau pas de poisson? pas de PIB
le système économique aujourd'hui
n'est encore une fois qu'une
énorme machine à transformer des ressources
qui ne sont nulle part
dans les indicateurs économiques
dont formation dont le coût de
formation n'est marqué nulle part dans les
indicateurs économiques nous utilisons
tant que ressources sont immenses par
rapport à notre activité c'est une bonne convention
l'approximation au premier ordre quand un
stock qui est immense et le prélèvement tout petit
ce n'est pas
s'emmerder avec le niveau du stock
et aujourd'hui notre activité est devenue
très significative par rapport au niveau du stock.
Et ne pas surveiller le niveau du stock,
nous conduit à des erreurs majeures.
Alors, vous savez, quand un ingénieur
a des théories fumeuses, il faut qu'il les
passe au banc d'essai. Vous avez, ici,
un graphique, qui vous donne, pour le
monde, dans son ensemble, la consommation
d'énergie depuis 1965 et
la variation du PIB depuis 1965.
d'aucuns voyant cette courbe
avant l'exposé qui a précédé pourrait me dire "cela me
dit pas où est la poule et l'oeuf?" ce qui est tout à fait vrai
par contre si vous savez que le système s'organise comme
ça alors vous devez logiquement trouver quelque chose comme ça
logique
c'est logique
voilà une autre manière de présenter la même
chose vous avez ici de 1965 à 2011 un point par année
en abscisse vous avez la consommation
d'énergie mondiale, en ordonné vous avez le PIB mondial
vous voyez
"dis-moi combien d'énergie tu
consommes je te dirais combien tu fais de PIB"
pas la peine de s'embêter à faire
des anges ou je ne sais quoi, très simple
par contre ce n'est
pas une affaire de prix
vous avez ici le PIB mondial en
fonction du prix du baril depuis 1960
pourquoi le prix du baril? parce que les trois
quart du prix payé pour l'énergie c'est du pétrole
et par ailleurs le prix du pétrole
sauf le gaz aux états-unis pour les années
récentes a asservi le prix des autres
énergies il a asservi le prix du gaz dans
toutes les autres régions du
monde il a asservi de prix du charbon
vous voyez que de 1965 à ici on
est en 1974 le prix du baril baisse
légèrement avec un PIB qui
monte puis le prix du baril augmente
violemment avec un PIB qui
monte puis baisse violemment avec un PIB
qui monte avec un prix du
baril à peu près constant puis
le PIB monte avec un prix du
baril qui augmentent fortement etc
il n'y a pas de lien entre le
PIB mondial et les prix du baril
il ya un lien entre l'endettement
français et le prix du baril que je vous monterai
juste après mais là pas de lien
entre PIB mondiale et de prix du baril
c'est juste un transfert de rente
donc régler le problème
énergétique en attendant que le prix de l'énergie
monte tout seul c'est accepter que la rente
parte chez les producteurs d'hydrocarbures c'est juste ça
c'est juste ça
évidemment nous cela
ne fera pas nos affaires
alors voilà ce qu'on paye au
producteur d'hydrocarbures depuis 20 ans
il y a moins
d'argent en jeu vous allez voir
voilà ce qu'on paye aux
producteurs d'hydrocarbures depuis vingt ans
en milliards de dollars constants
c'est pour l'Europe dans son ensemble
vous voyez que la facture
pétrolière européenne pétrogazière a été
multipliés en gros par 10 en
l'espace d'une dizaine d'années l'essentiel
c'est du gaz un peu du pétrole
vous savez probablement que quand un
pays a un déficit commercial structurel
et ça se traduit par une
augmentation de l'endettement
on n'emprunte l'argent qui sert à
payer les fournisseurs c'est exactement ça
vous avez ici un calcul
qui a été fait ou vous avez
depuis 1993 ici la facture cumulée
de pétrole et de gaz importé que nous
avons en France et ici l'endettement
l'augmentation de l'endettement
de l'état français
alors vous allez me dire la France
est un pays latin tenu n'importe comment
avec des pignoufs qui ne savent pas compter
allons voir un pays sérieux qui s'appelle l'Allemagne
voilà l'histoire pour l'Allemagne
donc c'est pas une
affaire de couleur politique
ça serait simple si c'était une
affaire de couleur politique c'est une
affaire physique structurelle
pilotée par des systèmes dans
lequel le pas de temps c'est le demi-siècle
on va dire qu'on n'est pas sorti
de l'auberge et je vais finir avec ça
puisque je vois que le temps
s'écoule et que les impatients...
pour vous dire pourquoi à partir
de maintenant on va être en récession
de manière
structurelle je pense en Europe
prenons le PIB mondial
que dans ma grande sagesse
je dis qu'il est égal à lui même
j'espère qu'on sera d'accord jusque-là
je vais multiplier à droite et
divisée par l'énergie et là je fais
apparaître un terme qui
s'appelle l'efficacité énergétique du PIB
dit autrement
c'est combien d'euros de valeur
ajoutée je peux créer avec un kilowattheure de
changements physiques
je change le monde
ça a de la valeur pour moi
je transforme du minerai en
couteau etc...  tout et n'importe quoi
donc je change le monde
donc j'utilise de
l'énergie et ça a de la valeur pour moi
plus avec le même changement physique
j'ai créé de valeur pour moi
et plus mon économie est efficace
c'est ça le terme
"efficacité de l'économie"
je vais ramener ça aux
individus donc le PIB par personne
dit autrement les revenus des
gens le PIB par personne c'est la
c'est le revenu par personne
est strictement égal
strictement égale l'énergie par personne
fois l'efficacité énergétique
de l'économie
la variation du PIB par personne
est strictement égal logarithmiquement
et même là c'est vrai
la variation de l'énergie par personne
plus la variation d'efficacité énergétique
de l'économie
c'est beaucoup plus simple que
les grands modèles macroéconomiques
couplés dans lesquelles à part le
type qui a fait le modèle personne ne sait
ce qu'il en sera
l'énergie mondiale je
vous l'ait dit tout à l'heure
+2,5 % de croissance par
personne et par an avant 1980, 0,4% après
l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie en moyenne mondiale un peu
moins d'1% depuis 1970
ma théorie me dit que le PIB mondial
par personne devait croître de 3% avant 1980
ma théorie me dit que le PIB mondial par
personne devait croître de 3% avant 1980 en moyenne
il doit croître
aujourd'hui de 1% par an en moyenne
on va aller regarder ce que dit la
banque mondiale et la banque mondiale me dit :
la variation moyenne du
PIB par personne avant les chocs
pétroliers c'était 3% par
an et que la variation moyenne
du PIB et par personne
aujourd'hui c'est 1% par an
et donc je suis d'accord avec
M. Vittori quand il dit dans lesEchos
qu'à partir de maintenant il faut
que l'Assemblée Nationale vote le budget
avec une croissance nulle, zéro, zéro
c'est avec ça qu'il faut voter alors
en effet que ce soit
agréable ou pas, ce n'est pas le sujet
le sujet c'est : "est-ce que je
me cale sur le monde tel qu'il est
où est ce que je fais un plan
pour le monde tel qu'il n'est pas et à ce
moment mon plan ne marchera pas."
voilà pour la France
Où vous avez la variation du
PIB par personne donc vous voyez
une très belle marche escalier et si
j'avais le temps je montrerai ça pour d'autres
pays de l'OCDE et ça
marche extrêmement bien
deux ou trois trucs avant
de finir vous avez ici la même
chose que ce que je vous ai montré pour
l'énergie pour le pétrole
vous avez en rouge la variation de
la production de pétrole dans le monde
il s'agit bien de volume de barils
et en bleu la variation du
PIB par personne dans le monde
ce que vous voyez c'est
que l'asservissement est très bon
et non seulement il est très
bon mais sur les deux épisodes récents
c'est d'abord le pétrole qui
varie et ensuite le PIB par personne
qui varie donc, ce n'est pas "on
consomme moins de pétrole parce que c'est
la crise" c'est d'abord "il y a
moins de pétrole et ensuite c'est la crise"
et en fait d'abord ya moins de
pétrole pour des raisons physiques
vous allez voir après que
c'est pas le prix qui fait l'extraction
une fois que vous avez moins de
pétrole vous avez notamment dans le transport
donc un système qui se freine un peu
et à ce moment vous avez
moins de PIB le choc pétrolier
est une conséquence du fait que comme le
pétrole est vendu sur un marché
instantanément son prix augmente mais
ça n'est pas la diffusion du
choc pétrolier dans l'économie qui fait
baisser le PIB mondial puisque
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure qu'
il n'avait pas de lien entre
le prix du pétrole et le PIB mondial
ça change
instantanément l'allocation des rentes
donc ça fait la
fortune de l'Arabie saoudite
et ça fait le malheur
de l'Europe ça c'est vrai
mondialement ça change pas grand chose
C'est le volume qui change
Varitations sur le
volume variations sur le PIB
et en ce qui concerne la
production mondiale de pétrole et bien on y
reviendra qu'au moment des questions
voilà où on en est voilà
une projection sur la production
mondiale de pétrole sur
deux siècles on voit large
et nous sommes là
donc on y est à quelques
années près 5 ans près env.
la question que l'on se pose est
celle du prix mais je vous ai dit à mon avis
c'est pas la question alors un
petit zoom sur l'Europe pour finir
vous avez ici le pétrole à
disposition de l'Europe alors vous voyez le pétrole
de la Mer du Nord c'est en rose
rappelez-vous qu entre 2000 et
2008 le prix du pétrole a très fortement
augmenté la production de la
Mer du Nord a très fortement baissé
donc l'idée que quand le prix du
pétrole augmente on n'en trouve plus
on en extrait plus etc ....ça se discute
alors vous voyez également que
l'europe a perdu 10 % de son pétrole depuis 2006
donc ça date d'avant le grenelle de
l'environnement le fait qu'on consomme
de moins en moins de pétrole
et ça va continuer
pour le gaz voici un pronostic
central fait par Total qui montre que la
production mondiale de gaz
pourrait plafonner vers 2025 nonobstant le
développement des gaz
non conventionnel dans le monde
nonobstant le développement des
gaz non conventionnel dans le monde
donc je vous montre en passant à
quoi ça ressemble un "champ" de gaz non
conventionnel voilà j'ai quelques
doutes quant au fait qu'on puisse mettre
ça dans les Cévennes
et dans le Bassin Parisien
voilà comment évolue la
approvisionnement gazier en Europe
s'il vous plaît
voilà comment évolue
l'approvisionnement gazier en Europe vous voyez qu'il a
cessé de croître quand la Mer du
Nord qui représente 60% de notre gaz à
passé son pic
et donc j'ai quelques doutes
quant au fait que indépendamment de la
question climatique on puisse
remplacer le moindre nucléaire par du gaz en Europe
je ne suis pas
complètement sûr que ça va marcher
parce que je pense
que le gaz ne sera pas là
enfin je vais terminer avec un élément
sur le changement
climatique qui est juste ça
vous avez ici les émissions qui
permettent aux français de vivre comme ils vivent
c'est donc le bilan carbone du français
là dedans les
agents productifs ont disparu
d'accord il n'y a pas d'émission attribués
dans cette histoire à Renault, à Total ou à Bouygues
les émissions sont en
totalité attribués à vous et à moi
et elles sont incluses ces émissions dans la
fabrication des produits et services que nous utilisons
alors qu'est-ce quels sont les
produits et services qui utilisent les
français? ils font
construire de temps en temps
et cette construction sachant
qu'un mètres carrés de logements en
béton c'est à peu près 500
kilos équivalent CO2 pour le faire
l'essentiel est dans l'acier le
ciment nécessaire à la fabrication du logement
500 kilos équivalent CO2
dans un mètre carré donc la fois
où vous faites construire 100 mètres
carrés, clac! vous vous prenez 40 tonnes de CO2
après il faut
l'amortir sur le reste de votre vie
donc rapporté à un français et à
une année et ça fait en gros quelques
centaines de kilos de CO2 par
français et par an pour l'activité de
construction, des logements!
Pas des magasins,
pas des bureaux,
pas la rénovation
de l'Assemblée Nationale.
Ensuite, il faut avoir un
confort thermique, dans ces logements.
Donc, il faut
utiliser l'énergie pour ça.
Et ça, ça fait un peu moins de deux
tonnes équivalent CO2, par personne et par an.
L'essentiel est occupée par les usages
thermiques : chauffage et marginalement eaux chaudes.
Ici, vous avez les émissions correspondant
la production électrique, import/export inclus.
Ce calcul inclut les échanges aux
frontières de la France donc l'électricité
au charbon, qu'on importe de
l'Allemagne, de temps en temps, etc... c'est dedans.
Vous voyez que l'essentiel est dans
le confort thermique et, bien évidemment,
l'essentiel de ce confort thermique est lié au
fioul et au gaz utilisé, dans les chaudières domestiques.
Marginalement, là aussi, la
production électrique qui l'alimente.
Après les gens mangent.
alors là vous avez des
gaz hors CO2 vous avez le
méthane du cheptel bovin le
protoxyde d'azote de l'utilisation des engrais
et ce que vous voyez ici
c'est que l'alimentation c'est 2,5
tonnes équivalent CO2 par personne et par an
c'est plus que le chauffage des logements, c'est plus.
là dedans
la viande représente 40% et en
fait viande + laitages c'est à 50%
dit autrement le fait qu'on
ait envie de manger les animaux
c'est la moitié notre empreinte carbone
il faut savoir qu'en France
70% de SAU (surface agricole utile)
est dévolue à
l'alimentation des animaux tous les pâturages
et la moitié des surfaces céréalières
le fait qu'on ait
envie de manger les animaux
pèse lourd
dans l'empreinte carbone des français
ensuite vous avez ici
l'achat des biens manufacturés
hors alimentation donc là dedans
vous allez trouver vos petites cuillers, vos
machines à café, vos
chaussettes, vos chemises, vos chaussures
les automobiles quand vous en achetez
les agendas etc... absolument tous
les produits manufacturés qu'on
peut acheter vos lunettes sont la dedans
ce que vous voyez ici c'est que
la fabrication pas d'utilisation la
fabrication de l'engin que mon
voisin est en train de consulter ou de
l'ordinateur que je
suis entrain d'utiliser
c'est un coup bas,
je suis d'accord (Rires)
...j'y reviendrai...
la fabrication
de l'électronique utilisée par
les particuliers donc là dedans il n'y a
pas les ordinateurs des entreprises
donc les écrans de télévision
et les ordinateurs
des particuliers aujourd'hui
c'est un tiers de l'empreinte
carbone des achats de produits manufacturés
entre 1990 et 2010 l'empreinte
carbone des français a augmenté de plus de 10%
l'électronique grand public en
représentent les deux tiers au bas mot
donc penser que les technologies de l'information
dématérialisent la société, pour le moment c'est totalement faux.
c'est des usages qui sont venus
se rajouter en plus des bagnoles et du
chauffage des logements et qui ont
rajouté des émissions qui n'en n'ont pas supprimé
enfin ici vous avez l'énergie utilisée pour
déplacer des individus dans leur sphère privée
alors la sphère privée inclut dans ce
calcul aux déplacements domicile-travail
donc c'est le déplacement
domicile-travail + vous dans votre
sphère privée vous allez voir votre
mère vos enfants vous partez en vacances vous
allez faire les
courses enfin voila c'est tout ça
la partie ici c'est la voiture et
ça c'est l'avion ça c'est pareil entre
1990 et 2010 la part qui a augmenté
la dessus c'est essentiellement l'avion
je vous rappelle que l'avion est
essentiellement concentrée sur les deux
premiers déciles en tout cas en
loisirs il est concentré sur les deux premiers
déciles de la population
en gros
pour ce qui fait que rajouter un
nouvel aéroport est infrastructure pour
riches, pardon j'ai rien dit...
donc vous voyez ici les déplacements
= 2 tonnes équivalent CO2
et enfin vous
voyez, oui, c'est la réalité,
et vous voyez ici les services publics
et privés
qui représente aussi de
l'ordre de 2 tonnes équivalent CO2 par
personne et par an alors c'est quoi
ces services publics et privés? L'école!
Faut construire une école
les bâtiments et les chauffer
et très accessoirement
maintenant mettre des ordinateurs dedans
l'hôpital
il faut le construire, le chauffer
, il faut fabriquer le plateau technique
toute l'industrie
pharmaceutique et tous les Medical Systems ABCD
et ABCD
leurs émissions
vont se retrouver là-dedans
et c'est un peu l'Armée parce
que l'Armée crame pas mal de fioul
et de kérosène pour jouer à
la bataille navale et à la bataille
aérienne
et enfin ici vous
avez les services privés
la banque, le coiffeur et
les opérateurs de téléphone etc
ce que vous voyez donc c'est que
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
par temps l'usage de l'énergie
fossile sont logés dans tout ce que nous
faisons
toute la journée, partout!
et donc la caractéristique du
problème du changement climatique ou de la
dépendance à l'énergie fossile
c'est que c'est un problème que vous
ne pouvez pas résoudre en contraignant une
petite fraction de la population
au bénéfice des autres donc c'est pas
comme un problème
d'environnement classique on peut emmerder les
agriculteurs ou les fabricants de
piles au mercure où les gens qui font des
avions ou je ne sais
qui encore ou les chimistes
pour le bénéfice du plus grand nombre
c'est un problème
qu'on ne pourra résoudre
qu'en demandant une
part d'effort à tout le monde !
et là on va retomber sur
la noblesse de votre métier
je ne connais pas
historiquement d'exemple dans lequel on puisse
demander un effort collectif sans qu'il
y ait un projet collectif extrêmement sexy
dit autrement on ne sortira
jamais de se prennent sans vision
sans vision c'est le
chaos qui réglera la situation
évidemment c'est toute la question
de savoir comment on fait émerger une
vision en démocratie avec des pas de
temps de deux ans à part ça vous connaissez
par coeur
voilà pour fin des explications
préliminaires qui ont été un peu longues
désolé
et puis maintenant j'imagine
plein de questions
merci merci beaucoup
r est-ce qu'on pourra c'est
une question en e10 posait plus
de la présentation aucun problème
merci beaucoup beaucoup
donc je vais maintenant passer
la parole au représentants des groupes
j'ai commencé par le groupe
src donc Arnaud LeRoy et ensuite
Martial Saddier
pour le groupe ump Arnaud
merci Monsieur le président
M. Jancovici
je dois vous avouer que
les quelques
minutes qui m'ont été alloués
vous les avez dédiée autre
chose à savoir le changement climatique
si vous étiez climatologues
on avait dit on m'avait dit j'ai vu
quelques chroniques également dans les
L: échos il me semblerait que vous étiez
intéressé J : je n'ai jamais signé en tant que climatologue
j'ai cru j'ai cru
moi j'étais une vision de
l'esprit je vais mais bon je
vais je vais continuer de faire
pour le juste
donc sûr
j'ai pris connaissance de vos graphiques
très bien intéressante
une théorie qui mérite d'être
étudiée
je dois vous avouer que
moi je voulais parler climat
donc j'étais aussi j'étais
aussi curieux mais comme vous êtes un
ingénieur, je me suis dit porteur
de solutions dans la représentation on
recherche des solutions
un début d'explications deux
tentatives je suis d'accord avec vous sur un
point la démocratie
l'effort global nécessaire
et je pense que l'effort global
nécessaire  ne s'arrête pas qu'aux français
ça s'adresse aussi
à l'ensemble la planète
et je pense que c'est un des éléments
que votre
présentation loupe complètement
un rapport à la démocratie
il y a une question où vous
parlez tout à l'heure des précaires
énergétiques qui
semblerait être une illusion
je pense pas que ce
soit le cas et on est bouclée
c'est
L: globalement un peu ce que vous avez dit donc
moi je peux vous dire simplement J:non ce n'est pas vrai
que je viens de discuter
avec succès avec moult députés
d'Angleterre d'Allemagne d'Estonie
du Danemark et ce qu'on appelle les plus
pauvres
sont un problème majeur aujourd'hui
ils sont au coeur de la campagne
électorale en allemagne donc je pense
pas qu'on puisse dire que c'est
une fumisterie que le
poste énergétique dans le budget
global des familles n'a jamais été aussi
bas en tous cas il y a un ressenti
c'est comme l'humidité et la température
et on peut pas en termes
démocratiques nier cet aspect
deuxième point
l'acceptabilité je vous rejoints sur
un point il y aurait des efforts et que nous
devons en tant que politique avoir
une vision et surtout un plan de pédagogie
pour expliquer ces
efforts et le pourquoi
donc voilà un petit peu où nous
en sommes moi je voudrais aussi vous
entend parler d'ordres de la République
on est à l'assemblée et on est pas sous les
ordres de la République on
est dans une Chambre du peuple élu
on doit
pouvoir faire vivre
cette ambition démocratique
la
secrétaire générale de la
convention cadre sur les changements climatiques
Mme Christiana Figueres
voudrait voir
beaucoup plus d'implication
des autorités locales et des
parlements nationaux dans la mise en place du plan
post 2015 parce que je pense que
c'est un élément important vous avez
pointé cette date dans votre présentation
moi j'e voudrait qu'on s'y arrête deux minutes
la france a fait le choix
de se rendre disponible comme on
dit en jargon diplomatique pour accueillir
cette COP 21 en 2015
il y a une ambition très forte de la
part de nos gouvernements Laurent Fabius a
indiqué que la diplomatie
climatique été dorénavant un des axes
prioritaires de notre action extérieure
j'aurais voulu vous
entendre un peu sûr comment
participer enrichir accompagner
puisque nous avons encore
quasiment deux ans devant nous
quelles sont les pistes que vous
pouvez proposer notamment pour faire
émerger cette idée qui est
intéressante je reconnais qui est
percutante sur la
le problème de la disponibilité de
l'énergie et non pas simplement le prix
je vous trouve extrêmement critique
envers les énergies renouvelables donc
ça c'est quelque chose
qui m'a un petit peu chiffoné
surtout
M. Gest critique je confirme
assez silencieux sur
votre rapport au nucléaire
parce qu'on a l'impression que
le blâme
le blâme est sur
les énergies renouvelables
très peu prolixe sur
l'efficacité énergétique
donc voila moi on m'a donné quatre
minutes je vois que j'ai déjà dépassé
donc et maintenant je suis ravis avec
mes collègues du groupe src qui sont quand
même
heureux de vous accueillir ce
matin puissent poser leurs questions à leur
tour
Président : Merci, Merci Jancovici: Juste une réponse de pinaille, j'ai 16 heures
de cours en ligne à qui veut, si vous voulez passer de 45 minutes à 16 heures plus précis
donc des questions vont
être posées M. Jancovici aura la
possibilité d'y répondre
Martial Saddier pour le groupe ump
merci Monsieur le Président
Monsieur Jancovici
merci au nom des députés ump
de votre présence je voudrais
vous dire que vous venez d'exposer
vos travaux
vous l'avez fait vous le savez
avec brio vous maîtrisez parfaitement
et vous venez de nous exposer
un constat qui respectable on
peut être pour on peut être contre je le
dis à tous les collègues
de la commission mais vous avez un
raisonnement dont on ne peut pas dire au
moins que du début jusqu'à la fin il
n'y ait pas une certaine logique même si
on trouve que sur le fond
on peut en penser chacun ce que
l'on souhaite. Nous, les députés ump
voudrions souligner
un point profond d'accord
avec vous c'est l'enjeu sociétal
et c'est d'ailleurs en cela que
nous avions mis en place le grenelle 1 et
grenelle 2 de
l'environnement pour associer tout le monde
parce que l'enjeu effectivement
mérite
qu'il y ait consensus et
qu'il y ait surtout absence de
démagogie
et de populisme sur un sujet
aussi important pour relever les défis
qui ont été présentés
vous avez rappelé on peut pas nier
que le Président Sarkozy n'a pas vraiment
été remercié
mais vous avez aussi souligné le
destin funeste qui attend Monsieur Hollande
et qui a aussi menti sur un
certains nombre de choses alors sur la
réflexion sociétale
c'est la première question
il y a un autre grand pays
démocratique moderne qui utilise l'énergie fossile
où le président sortant a été réélu
Monsieur Obama
il y a eu un débat et notamment un
débat énergétique comment analysez-vous le
débat sociétal qui a eu lieu il
y a quelques semaines aux États-Unis
deuxième remarque par rapport à
votre raisonnement on parle, alors ce
n'est pas un avis, mais je
soulève des questions,  il s'écrit
beaucoup de choses sur
des réserves nouvelles potentielles
fossiles vous avez rappelé 300 millions d'années
pour faire du pétrole
100 millions pour le gaz
d'années
mais est-ce que notamment les
réserves potentielles dont on dit qu'elles
existeraient peut-être de gaz de schiste
suppression de la glace
Pôle Nord notamment
est-ce que cela peut changer
dans un temps court peut-être ou pas,
le raisonnement. Enfin vous n'en avez pas
fait référence
mais l'énergie nucléaire on a
bien compris qu'elles concernent
essentiellement l'élec
tricité vous l'avez rappelé
mais par rapport à votre raisonnement
quid de la décision qui a été
prise d'abaisser la part du nucléaire et
notamment
sur un exemple précis la
fermeture de la centrale de Fessenheim
pouvez-vous nous
donner votre avis sur ce point
Président : je passe la parole à
Yannick Favennec pour le groupe udi
merci Monsieur le Président,
Monsieur Jancovici je voudrais également vous
remercier au nom du groupe udi
pour cette présentation décoiffante
et je voudrais vous
interroger sur la conférence de Doha
et sur le leadership français
cette conférence n'a pas été un
échec pour l'Union Européenne elle
avait été le théâtre mondial de
la capacité des grandes puissances a
s'entendre sur des objectifs de
réductions d'émissions de gaz à effets
de serre
essentiels à la survie de l'humanité à
moyen terme. Dans ce concert de d'inertie
je crois que la France n'a pas à
rougir de son bilan dans sa lutte contre
les émissions de GES
(gaz à effets de serre)
en témoigne d'ailleurs une étude
récente allemande qui nous place parmi
les meilleurs élèves du monde
alors que le reste du monde de 2010 à
2011 connaissait une augmentation de 3% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
la France quant à elle les a réduites de
6% notamment grâce aux efforts
consentis dans le cadre du grenelle de
l'environnement. Dans ses performances
que nous devons encore amplifier, doivent
nous amener à prendre le leadership
au sein de l'Union Européenne
dans la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique mais où est
ce leadership qu'aujourd'hui
où est passé le
volontarisme de notre pays
qui nous conduisait il y a encore
quelques mois à imposer le plan climat énergie à nos
partenaires européens
dans le cadre de la présidence
française. Non seulement la voix de la
France a disparu
mais nous avons aussi céder
sur les avancées que nous avions
nous-mêmes porté, je pense, au fond
vert de la conférence de Copenhague qui
devait aboutir à mobiliser 100
milliards d'euros à l'horizon 2020 je
pense aussi aux aides destinées aux
pays qui seront les premières victimes
du réchauffement climatique je
pense à la taxe carbone aux frontières de
l'Europe la taxe sur les
containers ou sur les carburants
d'avions... alors j'ai deux questions
la première j'aurais voulu
connaître votre sentiment sur la conférence de
Doha et sur la position française au
cours de ce sommet quel doit être selon
vous le rôle de la France dans
ce domaine au sein de l'Europe et plus
largement dans le cadre des
prochains sommets internationaux et j'ai une
deuxième question
qui elle concerne la réduction de
la part du nucléaire dans le bouquet
énergétique français les énergies
renouvelables actuelles permettront-elles
de compenser la baisse de la part
du nucléaire à l'horizon 2025 ? Cette
réduction est-elle compatible avec
nos objectifs de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de
serre ? je vous remercie
Président : Merci, Denis
Baupin pour le groupe écolo
Merci Mr le Président et
merci M. Jean-Marc Jancovici pour son
exposé le ton provocateur qu'il a eu
et pour dire que sur les grands
fondamentaux de ce qu'il a dit nous
sommes d'accord
nous sommes d'accord sur le
diagnostic qui l'a posée sur le
fait que la crise dans
laquelle nous sommes n'est pas une crise
conjoncturelle qui pourra
repartir demain avec une croissance qui
redémarrerait par enchantement mais que
on est bien sur une crise qui est structurelle
avec des questions énergétiques
on est bien au cœur
de cette question de la crise
qui est posée et donc de ce point
de vue, bien, je pense que ce
qu'il dit, doit être entendue comme
un élément qui doit nous permettre
aux uns et aux autres de reconfigurer
certains de nos raisonnements
il y a là évidemment un sujet qu'il n'a pas
abordé et sur lesquels nous avons pas les même
positions c'est que je n'ai pas
entendu parler ni de Tchernobyl et de Fukushima
ni des impacts que ça pouvait avoir
y compris dans le calcul économique
si on intègre la question de
l'accident nucléaire dans le calcul
économique je pense qu'y
compris pour cette énergie ça doit
être
quelque chose qui permet de
réécrire les équations parce que je
partage le point de vue
qui consiste à dire il faut que
nous prenions en compte dans le
calcul économique tous ces éléments
qu'il a indiqué donc
donner un prix au carbone
donner un prix à l'épuisement
des ressources pétrolières donner
un prix à l'accident nucléaire tout
ça doit nous permettre de donner de la
rationalité dans le calcul
économique donc si nous sommes d'accord sur les
constats après reste la
question qu'il a peu évoqué
et qui nous paraît plus aujourd'hui
la plus importante c'est qu'est-ce que nous
faisons
de ces constats? et
comment nous abordons la suite
une fois qu'on a dit
qu'il fallait revoir les équations
économiques, il faut aussi
revoir les équations énergétiques
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à penser
la consommation
énergétique sur le même rythme
que celui ce qui a été
celui des années précédentes
même avec une population
qui va croissante
et quand l'Agencé
Internationale de l'Énergie
qui est donc je
rappelle l'organisme de l'OCDE
qui travaillent sur ces
questions énergétiques nous dit que
face à l'ensemble de ces
périls énergétiques les priorités
aujourd'hui devraient aller à 77%
dans la sobriété et dans
l'efficacité énergétique à 19% dans
les énergies renouvelables elle
dit clairement l'Agence Internationale de
l'Énergie
où doivent aller
nos efforts prioritaires
pour lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique et l'épuisement des
ressources fossiles je
me permets de vous dire que
puisqu'on parle souvent des
États-Unis comme un exemple sur l'année
2012 on a installé plus de
puissance éolienne aux États-Unis
qu'on a installé de
puissance de gaz voilà donc
ça dit sur ces questions
d'énergies renouvelables il
y a aujourd'hui des pays qui sont
largement plus avancés que la France
je me permets de rappeler aussi d'ailleurs
que
il y a aujourd'hui à 1662
éoliennes offshore en Europe
zéro en france donc nous avons un retard
conséquent. En matière
d'efficacité il a évoqué les
besoins
de repenser nos questions
d'alimentation oui c'est un secteur dans lequel on
pourrait réfléchir sur la part
de l'alimentation carnée
dans notre alimentation si on veut
repenser ces questions,
la question de la mobilité
c'est quoi la voiture de demain
est-ce que doit être aussi consommatrice
et aussi polluante qu'elle l'est
aujourd'hui, la question des bâtiments
et de la consommation
énergétique y comprit l'énergie les risques
spécifiques
tous ces appareils
électroménagers que vous avez cités je me permets
de rappeler que en Allemagne
le ménage allemand
qui n'est pourtant pas
moins doté en appareil
électroménager que le ménage français consomme 20%
d'électricité spécifique de moins
que le ménage français
et je ne compte pas le
chauffage électrique c'est encore 20%
dans la consommation
en plus des ménages français
en matière d'électricité dont on
voit à quel point nos marges de progression
sont importantes
par rapport à un pays voisin
et donc surtout sur ces questions
puisque la question doit
être posée de la croissance comme
dans ce pays on pense
souvent croissance égal emplois
j'ai pas fini même
il me reste 2 secondes
et donc nous devons investir
dans les secteurs qui sont les plus
intensifs en emplois
c'est une des questions essentielles
et donc en matière énergétique notamment
le secteur de la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
le secteur du transport collectif
le secteur des énergies renouvelables
sont des secteurs
bien plus intensifs
en emploi que les énergies
fossiles et fissiles donc voilà ce
que ce que je souhaitais dire donc le débat
sur la transition
énergétique aujourd'hui en France est
particulièrement utile il est
utile d'un point de vue environnemental et
il est utile d'un
point de vue économique
et pour ça je suis d'accord
sur le fait que nous avons besoin
devant une vision et un débat
on pense que en effet
c'est un sujet sur lequel on peut
porter un discours positif
sur la façon dont la
transition énergétique est une réponse par
rapport à la crise
Merci. Olivier
Falorni pour le groupe rrdp
oui merci Monsieur le Président et merci
Monsieur
de cet exposé qui bouscule quand
on ouvre un débat il est toujours utile
d'être un peu bousculé
même si on peut être en désaccord
à la relecture d'un certain
nombre de vos articles j'ai noté que le
modèle que vous défendez
privilégie en priorité la décarbonisation
si je me trompe pas
d'abord des bâtiments puis
de l'industrie lourde et enfin des
véhicules et je
vous rejoins sur ce point
mais quid de l'objectif de réduction
de 50% de la part du nucléaire
de la production électrique française
vous le savez la conférence
environnementale pour la transition
énergétique a fixé ce cap pour 2025
comme pour la part des énergies
renouvelables dans le mix énergétique
alors comment peut-on à la fois
promouvoir le véhicule électrique la
pompe à chaleur
et réduire la part du nucléaire
sans favoriser l'exploration de gaz
ou la production de biocarburants
alors à la lueur de vos connaissances
pourriez-vous nous
éclairer sur la sortie du tout pétrole
d'abord pour les véhicules
et sans avoir une vision trop
déformée du marché automobile où dans les grandes
villes, le taux de motorisation diminue
c'est un constat
indéniable dans les petites
et moyennes villes
ainsi que dans les zones rurales
l'automobile est aujourd'hui
indispensable et le taux de motorisation
augmente
alors est-ce que les
biocarburants de troisième génération produits à
partir de, je crois,
algues riches en lipides
et qui peuvent accumuler entre 60
et 80 % de leur poids en acides gras
ce qui pourrait laisser présager
une production annuelle d'une trentaine de
tonnes d'huiles par hectare
est-ce que ces biocarburants de
troisième génération
peuvent-elles être une réponse adaptée? à titre de
comparaison
le rendement du
colza est 30 fois inférieur.
et puis l'industrie concernée aussi
par la sortie du tout pétrole alors que la
production mondiale de pétrole ne va
plus beaucoup varier d'ici à
2020 elle se mettra à décroître ensuite
l'Europe connaît une baisse de
sa production de pétrole alors que ce
dernier représente 40% de son
approvisionnement énergétique et 33%
pour la France
alors la dépendance
de la France au pétrole
ne peut-elle pas s'envisager
grâce à l'exploitation des gaz de
schiste comme l'a souligné le rapport
de l'AIE pour les États-Unis
alors on le sait le retour
d'expérience américain n'est pas bon pour
l'environnement c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire
mais il existe d'autres formes
d'exploitation pour pallier les risques
de la fracturation hydraulique
alors que pensez-vous des
recherches qui vise à remplacer l'eau
utilisée
par d'autres liquides comme du gpl ou
même du gaz carbonique et puis n'existe-t-il
pas une exploitation
écologique des hydrocarbures
l'extraction du gaz de
houille contrairement au gaz de schiste
peut s'extraire sans
recourir à la fracturation hydraulique
et enfin je voulais aborder le
rapport énergie 2050 rendu au début de
l'année 2012
par le Centre d'Analyse Stratégique
qui propose
quatre scénarios incarnant des visions
contrastés
et des méthodologies diverses
pour aborder la question de la production
nucléaire
et au travers de vos publications
j'ai lu que vous étiez attachés à cette
énergie
alors lequel de ces
scénarios accélération du nucléaire
prolongation du parc actuel
réduction progressive ou sortie complète
devrions nous adopter pour
répondre aux exigences de la décarbonisation
ce scénario doit-il considérer le
développement de l'usage des pompes à
chaleur et des véhicules
électriques qui implique par ailleurs
une évolution du réseau de distribution
d'électricité intelligents
je voudrais évoquer en conclusion
l'exemple du Danemark qui
réfléchit déjà au développement de cette
technologie
et qui fait figure de bonne élève
alors pourriez nous
nous dire si cet exemple danois
qui au-delà de ses réflexions a déjà
inscrit
tout d'abord l'augmentation de
la part des énergies non renouvelables
à 35 % de sa production
énergétique deuxièmement la réduction de sa
consommation brute d'énergie
de 12% entre 2006 et 2020
troisièmement une production
électrique dominé par l'éolien à 50%
pourriez-vous
nous dire si la politique
danoise est la voie à suivre pour réussir
notre transition
énergétique je vous remercie
Merci, avant de passer la
parole à Patrice Carvalho dans le groupe
gdr
il y a 17 intervenants donc vous
vous préparez pour une minute chacun
bien, je vous ai prévenu
Patrice Carvalho pour le
groupe gdr Merci M le Président
écoutez la première
la première réaction c'est
que c'est une intervention qui
a mon sens
décoiffe un petit peu ce n'est
pas habituel dans les propos pour
tous ceux qui me connaissent savent
que je pratique pas non plus de langue de
bois et même parfois
assez durement mais là
j'avoue que l'exposé qui était quand
même un peu hard
même si je partage un certain
nombre de choses qui ont été dites
la première chose qui
me pose problème d'ailleurs
moi je connaissais Marx
ses explications sur la société
le capitalisme qui conduisit à la
crise sans fin qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
je connais maintenant Jancovici
qui a un peu amélioré cette réflexion
qu'on a connu
par contre
il y a des
contradictions qui ont été dites
vous dites attention l'explosion
si les gens peuvent plus s'alimenter
normalement il va y avoir l'explosion
ce que vous nous prévoyez c'est
l'explosion sur la fin inévitablement puisque
en fait si il n'y a
plus cette croissance en Europe
il n'y a plus satisfaction des besoins
et les besoins aujourd'hui
sont moins insatisfaits en France
on met 2 millions de
personnes dans les rues aujourd'hui
pour une loi sur le
mariage et en même temps
on a 6 millions de personnes
il y a 6 millions de personnes
qui vivent du chômage
au chômage on a des gens qui
arrivent pas à se loger qui arrivent pas à se
nourrir enfin des gens qui
arrivent pas à se soigner bon ça fait des
choses qui sont quand même ricrac
bon moi quand je vois la prospective
je me dit que tout ça c'est un petit peu
pour l'avenir compliqué
et puis
comment réduire notre façon de vivre
à moins qu'on veuille nous ramener un
petit peu à la vie en Afrique avec nos dames qui
vont taper dans nos
gamelles pour faire à manger...
ben non les hommes
ils sont à la chasse...
les hommes ils sont à la chasse...
et un retour en arrière
alors que moi je ne parle pas de tout
on va parler de nos
grand-mères qui faisait la lessive dans
les rues etc
les petites rivières bon on verra
tout ça d'accord mais ça me paraît un peu
compliqué
il y a quelque chose que je
partage fondamentalement c'est
la question qui concerne les médias
le rôle des médias
en fait c'est la pensée unique
il n'y a pas d'autre société possible
tout est foutu voir
ce qui s'est passé etc
tout est foutu, tout à la trappe
d'ailleurs même LCP
LCP qui est dans le
système le plus complet, appelée à
faire réfléchir
à faire s'exprimer les
députés et bien écoutez la
tous les jours
les uns et les autres pas
seulement quand vous y passez
elle n'apporte rien de
plus que TF1, FR2, FR3 etc
Président : un grand
balayage... Carvalho : alors moi (Rires.)
je voudrais quand même
je fais comme vous j'en profite
je voudrais perler aussi un petit
peu des possibilités de modifier les
ressources énergétiques
on est à l'âge de pierre encore
demain on devait faire de
l'énergie avec cette bouteille d'eau
pour des semaines
on sait pas faut espérer que le
scientifique soit capable un jour de faire autre chose
et puis à ce que je
regrette quand même c'est que
votre message est fort mais
c'est quoi les
perspectives? qu'est-ce que vous proposez?
Président : c'est la deuxième partie.
Caravelho : Beaucoup plus intéressant...
et puis j'ai eu
peur parce que à une partie
j'ai cru que vous
proposiez le suicide collectif
après un message
aussi dur (Rires.) Merci!
Président : un certain humour...
Merci
alors donc
Une minute Philippe Plisson
Plisson: M le
Président, une minute, ça va être dur
on ne peut partager votre
diagnostic... Président : simplement...
ce que je voulais vous dire
j'interromps Philip
pe une minute simplement
M. Jancovici
moi j'aimerais bien qu'il ne
réponde pas devant une salle vide
le problème on le vit
régulièrement donc j'aimerais bien qu'il ne réponde
pas dans une salle vide donc
respectez les temps de parole que je vous
donne je veux dire les
analyses elles sont faites, elles ont
souvent été faite, simplement,
c'est peut-être une question à laquelle
il pourrait répondre.
Donc Phillipe, c'est à vous.
donc on ne peut partager votre
diagnostic qui est malheureusement connu, ce
qui nous
intéresse, ce sont les solutions
vous partez du postulat qu'il
n'y aura plus de croissance, au lieu de
rester dans le modèle de
développement des années 70 ne pensez-vous pas que
cet inconvénient pourrait devenir
une chance en changeant radicalement de
modèle ce qui remettrait par
exemple les énergies renouvelables que vous
méprisez au coeur du dispositif ?
deuxième question dans ce contexte
pouvez vous nous donner votre position par rapport
à l'exploitation des gaz de
schiste et que pensez-vous des clathrates de
méthane "épée de Damoclès" climatique
aux ressources énergétiques potentielles
Président : Merci, à Jean-Marie Sermier
c'est bien, vous voyez Mr le Président
c'est d'ailleurs une question
que je partage avec Yves Albarello
vous avez
un constat qui est
partagé par le plus grand nombre
ce que je souhaiterais que vous
puissiez aborder c'est maintenant la
gouvernance d'une
réflexion sur l'énergie on voit bien
qu'on peut pas aujourd'hui dans ce
pays prendre des mesures alors qu'en même
temps en Chine
nous avons une centrale à
charbon qui s'ouvre chaque semaine
quelle gouvernance faut-il pour
qu'au niveau mondial on puisse avoir des
avancées significatives
vous parlé d'un projet "sexy"
pour l'avenir, le sexy c'est
forcément là où chacun peut s'y
retrouver est-ce que on a aujourd'hui
le temps nécessaire de bâtir un projet de
le faire valider par le
plus grand nombre y compris par les
autres pays pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions intéresser la population dans
la réflexion que vous avez proposé
et puis le dernier point vous avez à peine
abordé l'hydrogène en disant
que cela coûter cher énergiquement
l'hydrogène fatal selon vous
a-t-elle quand même un avantage?
Merci, Geneviève Gaillard
oui
Merci Monsieur le Président
je voudrais dire merci à
Monsieur Jancovici et lui dire que
effectivement je partage avec lui
les grands fondamentaux qu'il nous a
présenté je suis resté sur ma faim
parce qu'évidemment
vous ne présentez pas Monsieur
des solutions ou du moins
des perspectives de solutions
pour les années à venir alors je
voudrais vous poser deux questions :
la première c'est que l'on sait que
l'énergie la plus propre que celle que
l'on ne consomme pas est-ce que
la France aujourd'hui est armée pour
pouvoir rentrer dans la
transition énergétique et puis avancer dans ce
domaine-là ? deuxième
question - j'en ai 3 en fait -
question en termes de fiscalité
écologique est ce que vous avez des
choses à nous proposer parce
que là aussi nous avons une réflexion
importante et on sait qu'il y a
des choses à faire et troisièmement
quel est votre
réflexion sur l'aménagement du
territoire vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui on en a de grandes réflexions aussi
sur l'aménagement du territoire
les métropoles les territoires qui
se désertifient comment
est-ce que vous voyez demain avec les
problématiques qui se posent
dans notre territoire français? Merci.
Merci. M Edouard Philippe
merci et merci d'abord pour
la présentation qui était évidement
provocatrice mais aussi
perturbante et stimulante du point de vue
intellectuel
je voudrais vous poser deux questions
et faire une remarque la première question
c'est vous nous avez indiqué
qu'il était temps de prendre en compte les
indicateurs et notamment les
indicateurs de prélèvement sur les stocks
et j'aurais aimé savoir si en France ou à
l'étranger il y avait des recherches dans le
monde économique où dans le monde
la comptabilité nationale pour mieux
prendre en compte
ces éléments de
prélèvement sur les stocks
éventuellement
nous dire un petit mot
sur la taxe carbone en bref
ces indicateurs qui sont
comptables qui sont même économique et qui
permettrait de mieux
traduire la réalité tel que vous l'avez
décrite
ma deuxième question
vous avez finalement
dit peu de choses sur les
impacts de tout ce système sur le
climat et vous avez montré qu'il y avait
une diminution de la ressource
énergétique qu'il fallait prendre en
compte
mais vous n'avez
pas mis d'échelle de temps
sur l'impact lié sur les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui était lié à cette
ressource énergétique la 3e chose
je fais très vite, c'est
dire quand même que c'est un
message
que moi je considère comme un
message intéressant et d'espoir parce que au
fond pour nous,
parlementaires, pour nous, élus politiques,
vous dites
qu'en réalité nous ne serions pas
condamnés
mais que c'est à nous d'inventer les
réponses qui doivent prendre en compte la
réalité que vous décrivez
et donc finalement, je
le prends comme un message de
prise de pouvoir des élus et pas un
message de condamnation des élus. Merci.
Président :à nous de prendre
nos Responsabilités. Jacques Krabal,
qui ne pourra pas parler
Jean-de-la-fontaine à mon avis.
J'en suis vraiment navré donc pour aller
vite
je voudrais revenir sur
les énergies hydrocarbures non
conventionnels
vous n'en avez pas
beaucoup parlé seulement à travers un
slide et que vous dites une remarque sur
les gaz et huiles de schiste
en faisant penser que vous dites que
vous êtes
défavorable pour quelle raison?
après vous semblez faire
apparaître certains défraiements à l'égard des
énergies renouvelables simplement à
travers le fait qu'elle représente peu
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres arguments
? concernant le nucléaire vous n'en avez
pas du tout peur vous citez même
dans votre livre j'aimerais bien avoir
quelques commentaires parce que
vous êtes assez sûr de vous, est-ce que
vous revenez sur cette
expression en disant que concernant la
catastrophe de Tchernobyl
à ce jour aucune étude
épidémiologique n'a pu mettre en
évidence un quelconque
surplus de mortalité par cancer de
cet accident mise à part les
quelques dizaines de décès que cela représente
alors qu'on sait bien dans
d'autres véhicules que ça peut aller de 5000 à
80.000 morts donc que vous êtes
assez agrégé en certitude dans votre
expression j'aimerais
savoir si vous le maintenez par
rapport à cette
assertion qui apparait aujourd'hui
Merci. Sylviane Alaux.
Oui, mes question vont
peut-être paraître un peu décalé par
rapport à la nature de votre
exposé mais je vous ai lu concernant le gaz
de schiste
ce que vous appelez la fausse
bonne idée et je profite donc de votre
présence parmi nous aujourd'hui
pour vous poser quelques questions la
première sur quelles études
vous basez vous pour affirmer cela
parce que finalement la
réalité et qu'on bloque sur la méthode
d'extraction qu'il est vrai
particulièrement dommageable pour notre
planète
la deuxième question ne doit-on
pas encourager la recherche pour trouver
d'autres méthodes d'extraction
d'ailleurs certains pays
commencent à s'y atteler doit-on rester les bras
croisés à attendre pendant
qu'ils cherchent, j'aurais aimé avoir
votre sentiment sur ces deux
questions, sur ces deux sujets, Merci.
Merci, Jacques Kossovski
Merci Président, Monsieur,
dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
je vous sais très
partisan du recours à l'énergie
nucléaire civile, qui d'après
vous, serait beaucoup moins dangereuse que
par exemple le charbon
vous pensez que l'élévation de
température sur notre planète aura un
impact beaucoup plus grave que
l'écosystème de cette catastrophe
disons dans les centrales sur ce qui
vient d'être dit tout à l'heure je vous ai
lu aussi
et même si cela doit faire réagir
certains de nos collègues, et c'est le cas
je souhaiterais que vous puissiez
nous expliciter votre position en faveur du
nucléaire dont l'utilisation en
terme apparaît comme très contestée par le
gouvernement actuelle, merci.
Merci, à Brigitte Allain
oui merci Monsieur le Président
je vais concentrer ma
question sur l'alimentation
dans votre exposé nous avons vu
tout à l'heure que l'alimentation a un fort
impact concernant nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
vous savez je suppose que
des scénarios ont été étudiés
concernant l'évolution de
nos besoins alimentaires d'ici 2050
parce que c'est bien de là qu'il
faut partir si on ne veut pas diminuer
notre alimentation en tous les cas
ça suppose de réels changements
mais les scénarios
ne prévoient effectivement
une alimentation qui
évolue mais aussi des besoins
énergétiques
donc ça suppose de changer
fondamentalement de politique agricole
que pensez-vous des
scénarios qui ont été proposée
par Afterres par exemple
et qui implique notamment des
régions
pour évoluer vers d'autres pratiques
et qui disent clairement qu'il
faudra un rendement croissant d'adoption
c'est-à-dire que s'il n'y a pas une
adoption
quasi générale des politiques
de ceux qui pratiquent l'agriculture
de tout l'entourage il ne
peut pas y avoir d'évolution
donc
ce sont ces scénarios qu'il
faut mettre en œuvre et donc avoir
une réelle politique
Merci. Serge Bardy
Merci, M le
Président, M Jancovici vous l'avez
dit chacun d'entre nous est
bien entendu d'accord en tant que
législateur peut et doit
s'intéresser à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
établir un cadre juridique alors
il y a quand même au niveau
mondial comment pourriez-vous nous indiquer à
votre avis quels sont les points
de blocage qui depuis vingt ans après le
sommet de la terre de Rio rendent
aussi ardue et inopérante la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique au niveau
international et notamment au regard des
institutions en charge de cette lutte
dans divers documents que vous
avez publié vous esquissez quelques
pistes sur le programme d'action qui à
vos yeux serait souhaitable en la matière
alors deux questions : moi j'ai noté
une proposition résidant sur la nomination
d'un conseiller technique dans
chaque cabinet de chaque ministère et dans
chaque direction générale européenne
ou envoyer dans une Cour des
Comptes rebaptisé Cours du Développement
Durable pouvez vous nous
préciser cette proposition? quelle
serait le rôle
précis de ses conseillers?
par ailleurs vous dites aussi que
vous évoquez la baisse nécessaire la
demande en
électricité, de chaleur et de mobilité
en période de crise comment
concilier une forte augmentation des tarifs
énergétique sans diminuer
brutalement le niveau de vie des français dont une
grande partie est d'ores et déjà
fragilisée
l'augmentation des tarifs de
l'énergie pour eux auraient des conséquences
catastrophique pourriez
vous nous confirmez votre réflexion
en la matière ? et je voudrais
terminer par une petite provocation et constructif
aussi, quelle proposition
pourriez-vous nous faire pour concilier
engagement 41 du
Président Hollande à savoir une baisse
de la part du nucléaire de 75 à 50%
avec une baisse de nos émissions de CO2
Merci.
Essayez de respecter, s'il
vous plaît. Jean-Pierre Vigier
Merci Monsieur le Président
Monsieur Jancovici, je vous remercie
pour votre brillant exposé, que j'ai bien
apprécié, qui décoiffe et qui
change des exposés classiques que l'on a
le gouvernement aujourd'hui
veut réduire la part du nucléaire mais
il faudra bien remplacer
cette part d'énergie et vous l'avez
déjà dit
ce n'est pas l'éolien et le
photovoltaïque qui vont remplacer en
totalité cette manque d'énergie
nous avons le gaz le charbon le
pétrole mais plusieurs problèmes on sera
dépendant des autres pays
on polluera pardon beaucoup plus
par émission de CO2
et d'après votre exposé si
bien compris les ressources en
charbon diminue fortement
alors deux questions que fait-on?
et quelle est votre
position sur le sujet?
Merci. Charles-Ange Ginesy
Oui, M Jancovici, merci pour
cet exposé qui est effectivement
porteur d'éclairage nouveau
et pour ma part je voudrais vous
poser une question qui consiste à dire et
je suis d'accord avec vous qu'il
faut dans la transition énergétique
moins consommer d'énergies fossiles mais
en même temps vous nous
expliquez que les énergies renouvelables ne
représentent rien
sur la part énergétique
donc ne peut-on pas trouver dans
cette diminution de notre consommation
un équilibre qui fasse qu'on ne se
trouve pas en décroissance parce que ce
qui m'a le plus marqué c'est quand
vous dites que je préconise le budget à
croissance zéro, je préconise un
budget qui n'avance plus or on sait qu'
économiquement parlant
si il n'y a pas de croissance
notre société ne trouvera pas une capacité
à rebondir
et puis ce qui m'a interpellé
également c'est le fait que vous disiez que
sur la recherche il n'y a
pas de possibilité d'obtenir un
avenir je crois pour ma part
que la recherche doit représenter
une nouvelle espérance
Merci. Christophe Priou.
Merci, M le Président.
Un peu comme le plombier
polonais, quel avenir pour le pêcheur breton?
va-t-il pouvoir
continuer à aller en mer?
la ressource s'il faut manger
moins carné, le poisson et aussi
d'élevage
énergie et puis le
marin-pêcheur il faut qu'il se loge et on a vu
certaines cartes la pression c'est
clair la population est en étalement urbain
et vers le littoral vers la
maison du pêcheur est devenue une résidence
secondaire et qu'on construit
maintenant pour les jeunes pêcheurs sur les terres
agricoles donc quel
urbanisme pour demain?
quand on voit également la part
de consommation de la construction de
logements et de
l'énergie pour éviter celui-ci?
Jean-Louis Bricout ensuite M Heinrich
Oui
M Jancovici, M le Président
excuser moi de mon retard j'ai
pas pu apprécier votre intervention
j'ai dû louper quelque chose
mais je crois que dans vos travaux
vous appelez nos villes à se
moderniser notamment du point de vue de l'urbanisme
et de l'aménagement du territoire
de même vous plaider pour que les
collectivités aient à s'équiper d'une taxe
carbone je crois
donc pour autant vous
n'êtes pas sans ignorer la complexité
le contexte financier difficile
dans lequel les collectivités ont à
boucler leur budget c'est
pourquoi ma question sera simple comment
envisagez-vous la
mise en place de cette taxe
d'une façon plus générale dans
votre théorie quel rôle assignez vous à
l'état dans sa mission
d'accompagnement des collectivités territoriales
Merci Michel Heinrich
Madame Sophie Rohfritsch ensuite.
M le Président je vais être bref
vous avez conclu Monsieur
Jancovici merci encore pour votre exposé qui
en fait nous a réveillés ensuite
peut-être un peu abasourdi vous disiez vos
conclusions on ne
sortira pas du problème sans vision
ou c'est le chaos qui réglera le
problème à votre avis chaos ou capacité
d'avoir une vision et
concernant la taxe
carbone appliqué à un pays
peut-elle être un
gadget temporairement utile?
Merci Madame Sophie Rohfritsch
oui merci Monsieur le Président
je dois avouer que cet
exposé a effectivement été passionnant
comme certain ou la
plupart d'entre nous n'ont pas tout
compris mais peut-être compris quand
même qu'avec ce nouveau modèle que vous nous
proposez le débat ce n'est plus sur
la transition énergétique mais c'est sur la
transition tout court
et qu'on a une formidable
occasion ou plutôt une opportunité vu
que le coût du capital n'a jamais été
si peu cher d'investir
massivement enfin pour développer le cas échéant
des énergies
renouvelables ou investir massivement
peut-être pour développer
le nucléaire dont finalement le
rendement est maximum en tout cas
en matière de production électrique donc
question sur le nucléaire
comme beaucoup d'autres de mes
de mes collègues ensuite quel
est le bon échelon de réflexion pour
un élu est-ce que c'est
vraiment le petit territoire
la France l'Europe évidemment
l'idéal ce serait le monde mais on peut pas
réfléchir
tous ensemble et adopter les mêmes
positions enfin dans un de vos articles
vous suggériez
puisque les prévisions de
l'AIE sont jamais conforme finalement
à ce qu'elle prétendait être la
création d'une commission parlementaire
sur les travaux de l'AIE et
sur la meilleure façon de prévoir les
quantités d'énergie notamment fossiles
peut-être le Président pourrait
aussi
suggérer la création de
cette commission pour que nous aussi
nous saisissions du sujet
Yves Albarello
et merci Monsieur le
Président Monsieur Jancovici une question
volontairement provocatrice
je vous écoute moi je
vous écoutais vous m'écoutez
j'ai une question
volontairement provocatrice
est-ce que nous persistons pas dans
l'erreur à vouloir améliorer sans arrêt
notre
bilan carbone lorsque le plus
gros consommateur d'énergie fossile
au monde la Chine
ouvre, et j'ai été effaré
par le chiffre cité tout à l'heure
une centrale à charbon par
semaine et donc forcément le bilan
carbone est négatif en Chine
plus positif chez nous et donc ça
s'annule est-ce qu'on persiste pas dans
l'erreur ou alors la règle du jeu...
Président : si ce n'est que la Chine est
le pays qui investit le plus dans les énergies
renouvelables il faut aussi
le signaler Jancovici : pouvez répondre
mais pas moi?  Président : oui oui oui... (Rires.)
je veux je voudrais simplement
dire que je vais simplement dire que le
temps de parole dont je dispose
est très peu utilisé jusqu'à jusqu'à
maintenant on aurait pu le constater
je suis quand même d'une
très grande réserve et en général
j'évite de piéger les
parlementaires qui sont là pour poser des
questions pour écouter pour
échanger bien entendu avec les personnes
qui étaient invités
mais c'est vrai que je suis
particulièrement vigilant et
respectueux des responsabilités des
parlementaires de cette
commission voilà ce que je
souhaitais dire...
voilà merci beaucoup vous
êtes gentil! David Douillet,
pour une minute merci.
Monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues,
dans une tribune qui est parue le
6 janvier dans le Journal du Dimanche
vous expliquez donc vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure, donc vous dites
que sans énergie,
je vous cite, à profusion
il n'y aurait aujourd'hui ni
pouvoir d'achat multiplié par 50
multiplié par 50
en 150 ans, une
baisse du temps de travail ;
les "35 heures"
ni aliments à profusion en toute
saisons, ni de mobilité pour tous, ni
espérance de vie passée
de 25 à 80 ans en deux siècles
etc...
si l'énergie est, comme vous le
développez dans cette tribunes, et comme vous l'avez
développé tout à l'heure
la base de l'ensemble de l'économie
comment vous envisagez
si mes chères collègues
me laissent parler (Rires.)
la transition énergétique
qui serait alors une transition
beaucoup plus globale de notre modèle économique
actuel, pas un simple glissement
d'une énergie à une autre, et puis,
Est-ce que vous pensez que
en France, nous sommes en retard
ou avons-nous anticipé les choses ?
Merci, les deux derniers
intervenants : Alain Gest et ensuite
Jacques-Alain Bénisti, Merci.
Merci M le Président,
M Jancovici, cela fait la troisième fois que je
vous écoute et à chaque fois c'est un vrai bonheur
parce que c'est un
c'est un discours
qu'on n'entend pas souvent
Tout à fait (au Président)
Le Président vous soutien
mais il faut quand même pas exagérer
(Rires)
je voulais simplement vous
demander, je vous ai déjà entendu dire, et pas
qu'aujourd'hui, que la solution
au problème des carburants automobiles,
compte tenu de ce qui va arriver
sur le plan du pétrole, vous êtes sur une
ligne proche de Yves
Cochet, dans ce domaine
c'est qu'il fallait multiplier par 2,
voire par 3, le prix des carburants vous
avez dit à l'époque d'ailleurs dans
la mission "Réchauffement climatique" qu'on
vous confierait volontiers le poste de
Ministre, qui va bien, pour l'expliquer aux
citoyens
et puis, je vous ai vu, dans un article,
que la commission nous a intelligemment adressé
d'ailleurs
vous parlez des tarifs subventionnés,
sur le gaz et l'électricité,
et pour dire que ce n'était pas
comme ça qu'il fallait s'y prendre
je aimerai connaître un petit peu,
votre avis sur la vérité des prix, en matière
d'énergie.
Merci,
pour conclure Jacques-Alain Bénisti.
Oui, merci Monsieur le Président,
une question que je voulais poser
à M Jancovici,
ce matin, un énième séisme,
d'amplitude 8
donc a eu lieu dans le
Pacifique face aux îles Fidji,
pas très loin d'ailleurs de
la Nouvelle Calédonie actuellement
en alerte maximale,
Pensez-vous qu'il y a
un rapport de cause à effet,
entre le changement
climatique et les mouvements géologiques
que les connaissons de
plus en plus ces derniers mois ?
Merci, eh bien écoutez M
Jancovici, vous avez la parole.
Beaucoup de sujets.
Bigre! alors ça va
peut-être un peu décousu,
je vais commencer par deux
ou trois remarques générales.
La première c'est que, comme vous vous en
doutez bien, je ne vais pas pouvoir répondre, de manière
détaillée, à toutes
les questions de détails,
il y en a un certain nombre, quand je dit de
détail : c'est une technique particulière, etc...
pour ceux qui ont le temps, je sais
que c'est une denrée précieuse, pour vous,
encore plus que pour moi
il y a des réponses
sur mon site personnel
de temps en temps, je vous dirais
"oui, conférez, ce que j'ai écrit sur le sujet"
parce que malheureusement j'aurais pas
le temps de le traiter ce matin, je pense plus
utile, de vous livrer des
choses un peu plus générales.
La deuxième chose c'est qu'il y a une
remarque que je fais très souvent, dans une
intervention, c'est d'expliquer que
les malentendus vont toujours se nicher
dans ce qui n'a pas été dit,
et en 45-50 minutes, on
fait un exposé de 45 ou 50 minutes.
un certain nombre d'entre vous ont
fait la remarque à laquelle je souscris,
évidemment, qu'on ne parle pas
de transition énergétique en parle
transition tout court, et on parle
de projet de société à long terme, en
gros, il s'agit d'aller conquérir la Lune quoi, il
ne s'agit pas d'une affaire de transition énergétique
à partir du moment où on accepte
l'idée, qu'on va toucher à tout, dans
cette affaire,  expliquer
"la Solution à tout" en 45 minutes,
si quelqu'un la solution,
dans cette salle, je prends!
ça m'intéresse beaucoup, je recyclerai,
c'est de circonstance, dans plein d'autres occasions!
La deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
que je vais impressionner mes filles, ce soir,
en leur disant que j'ai parlé à un
champion olympique, et ça c'est quand quelque chose!
(Rires)
Non, non, c'est normal, vous savez, il faut aller chercher
les gens là où ils sont donc des adolescentes de 16 ans donc voilà
et en fait, je vais en faire une
remarque beaucoup générale, il faut
aller chercher les gens là où ils sont!
les idées que les
gens vont aller tout seuls
la où il faudrait qu'ils
aillent, malheureusement, ça ne marche pas,
donc il faut vraiment aller
chercher les gens, là, où ils sont.
Quelques questions ont
été posées sur les ressources
et notamment, sur les gaz de
schistes alors ça je vais y répondre.
Ordres de grandeur :
l'Europe consomme aujourd'hui 500
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz par an
là-dedans 300 Mds
viennent de la Mer du Nord
le détail du calcul est sur mon
site donc je vous donne juste le résultat
ce qu'on pourrait obtenir des gaz
non-conventionnels est de l'ordre de
quelques dizaines de
milliards de mètres cubes par an en Europe
voilà c'est ça l'ordre de grandeur.
Sur une consommation
annuelle qui fait, aujourd'hui, 500 Mds.
Je vais vous donner, maintenant, un cas
plus particulier qui est celui de la France.
La France c'est 50 milliards de mètres cubes
par an, dedans il y a 30 dans le chauffage et 15
dans l'industrie
Si le seul problème, c'est de
satisfaire les demandes des chimistes français
en conservant 15 Mds de
consommation de gaz naturel en France,
on s'en sort sans problème,
et la question est de supprimer les
30 qu'on a dans le chauffage, qui soit dit,
en passant, nous coûte de 6
milliards d'euros d'importations par an.
et ça, ça se fait avec de l'isolation et
les pompes à chaleur on n'a pas besoin de gaz
pour ça.
Donc sortir le gaz et le fioul des
usages thermiques, dans le bâtiment, est
une des premières priorités, à mon
sens, dans toute "conquête de la Lune"
puisque moi, c'est comme ça le
nom que j'ai envie de lui donner,
et j'ai d'autant
plus envie de lui donner
ce nom là que comme je l'ai dit un
certain nombre de fois, il va falloir
demander de l'effort à tout le
monde et l'effort partagé par tous n'est
possible que quand tu as un truc un
peu excitant en face. Quand vous dites
à un astronaute
qui va aller sur la Lune,
il est d'accord pour se mettre, une
semaine, dans une boîte de conserve pour
risquer sa vie, pour
pas voir sa femme etc...
et tout ça parce que en face
il a un truc qui l'excite beaucoup
je pense que si on n'a pas, et ça c'est votre métier,
je suis désolé, c'est pas le mien, si on a pas une vision
exaltante, à long
terme, a proposer au pays
c'est pas la peine de songer à la
bonne manière de lui demander des efforts, on
peut bricoler, poser des rustines
etc... mais c'est pareil c'est pareil
et c'est exactement le même sujet, soit
dit, en passant, pour l'argent, je vais prendre
un exemple tiré de la vie courante.
Si un de vos enfants vient vous
voir en vous disant "Papa ou Maman, j'ai
déconné... excusez-moi, Parent, voici,
voilà, enfin pardon... et donc Papa ou Maman,
j'ai déconné et j'ai 500 euros de trous
sur mon compte en banque, il faudrait boucher..."
Vous allez traîner les pieds, le
faire une fois, parce que vous l'aimez bien,
la deuxième fois, vous allez commencé
à trouver que la plaisanterie a assez duré.
Le même viens vous voir une semaine
après, en disant : "Papa ou Maman, j'ai un
projet pour l'avenir, et
j'ai besoin de 10.000 euros !"
Vous les avez, vous payez!
Vous ne les avez pas c'est un
autre sujet, vous les avez, vous payez!
Donc là, on est exactement dans la
même configuration, on n'arrête pas de se
demander, où on va trouver de l'argent
pour faire des trucs, dans un sens ou dans un
autre, avec une mentalité de "bouchage"
de "pose de rustines" ...on va bricoler...
et on ne trouvera pas la
moitié des machins dont on a besoin
si on est dans une optique de "conquête
de la Lune" l'argent ce n'est plus le sujet!
L'argent ce n'est
pas le sujet, on le trouve!
On a trouvé mille milliards pour
sauver les banques, c'est pas le sujet.
C'est vraiment pas le sujet.
Ce qui est le sujet, c'est
l'arbitrage et on n'aura pas de l'argent pour tout
ça j'y reviens, on n'aura pas, à la
fois de l'argent pour donner un travail à tout
le monde, donner de l'espoir à tout
le monde, et donner plus de consommation à
tout le monde, ça on ne l'aura plus.
Préserver la stabilité socio-économique du pays
avec de l'espoir et un travail pour tous, ça on en trouve.
C'est vraiment pas le sujet.
La deuxième remarque un peu générale,
que je voudrais faire qui se rapproche à ça
C'est quid de la France dans les
négociations internationales climat.
Alors je vous l'ait dit : l'énergie fossile
c'est le pouvoir d'achat et c'est le niveau de vie
jamais, en fait, quand vous
reprenez les choses comme ça, jamais vous
ne parvenez à la conclusion
que des hauts fonctionnaires aussi
méritants soient-ils peuvent se
réunir quelque part dans le monde et décider
de leur côté de niveau rationnel de
consommation des individus, dans le monde,
ça ne peut pas marcher
ce qui peut marcher, c'est qu'une
région du monde, parce qu'elle est le
dos au mur se lance dans cette
affaire de cette manière, extrêmement résolue,
structurée et massive. Alors la
raison pour laquelle, j'ai attiré votre
attention, ce matin, sur la
particularité de la situation énergétique de
l'Europe en matière
de carburant et de gaz,
c'est parce que je vous dis l'Europe
est le dos au mur donc notre choix sans regret
c'est de nous lancer de
manière résolue, dans une économie qui
utilise de moins en moins de
combustibles fossiles! Ça doit être ça,
notre "conquête de la Lune"
et ça doit, nous occuper 40 ans!
Et c'est pas une transition à 100
Mds, c'est une transition à 5.000 Mds
un calcul d'ordre de grandeur. L'ordre
de grandeur des investissements, qu'il faut
consentir, pour refaire les villes,
refaire les infrastructures de transports,
refaire le paysage agricole, parce
que le paysage agricole qu'on a fait,
aujourd'hui, ne convient pas à
un monde, sous stress énergétique,
un camion sur trois transporte
quelque chose qui se mange donc le paysage
agricole qu'on a organisé
aujourd'hui, ne convient pas
à une raréfaction
significative l'approvisionnement énergétique !
Alors, refaire tout ça,
c'est 40ans et c'est quelques milliers de
Mds alors je ne sais pas si c'est 4.000, 8.000 ou
10.000 milliards d'euros mais,
pour moi, c'est une très bonne nouvelle
ça veut dire qu'on a une colonne
vertébrale autour de laquelle, il doit
nécessairement y avoir le même
consensus politique que pour le fait d'avoir
des caisses de retraites sinon on s'en
sortira jamais ! et il faut que vos divergences
s'expriment à la marge, sur des petites manières,
des petits machins concernant la gestion du problème.
Un peu plus de marché,
ici, un peu plus d'État là, voilà.
Mais si ça va au delà
de ça, ça ne marchera pas !
Donc à un moment, on a besoin de
quelque chose, qui ressemble à une Union
Nationale, sinon on
va vers le bazar pour tous.
Extrêmement bien partagé, mais je suis pas sûr que vous
ayez été élu député, pour vous occuper de ce genre de choses.
En ce qui concerne le nucléaire, où là
aussi énormément de questions ont été posées,
alors la réponse courte est que je pense que c'est
une bien meilleure idée, qu'une mauvaise, dit autrement,
la phrase exacte que j'ai envie
d'utiliser c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
nucléaire évite beaucoup plus
d'inconvénients qu'il n'en crée.
Il en crée, c'est absolument certain, ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure, l'énergie "propre" n'existe pas !
Pas plus pas plus...
(à M Baupin) je suis pas sûr!
je suis pas sûr parce que
ce n'est pas lui "cirer les
pompes" on trouve, aujourd'hui
en effet, allé je vais vous taquiner,
au sein du parti Vert, un certain
nombre de gens qui tête à tête entre la poire
et le fromage, quand personne ne les écoute,
à la limite, s'il n'y avait que ça comme sujet de
dissension, "oui, enfin, bon, il va bien
mais on met ça dans un coin... et on en parle plus"
M. Denis Baupin: Il faut les virer ! (Sourires)
Vous avez tort!
Il faut les écouter ! (Rires.)
M. Denis Baupin: Il faut les virer ! (Sourires)
Vous avez tort!
Il faut les écouter ! (Rires.)
ah ch'ais pas (Sourires)
Donc j'insiste, ça crée des inconvénients ça en crée
moins que les inconvénients que ça nous permet d'éviter.
C'est une affaire d'arbitrage.
Sur toute la partie technique
combien de morts à Tchernobyl et
combien de déchets etc, je vous renvoie à tous mes
écrits sur mon site, vous avez une avalanche de chiffres
toutes les méthodes et les
sources y sont donc comme ça vous
pourrez voir pourquoi
je pense ceci et pas cela
en ce qui concerne... il y a une question
aussi fondamentale qui a été posée, à un moment,
qui est celle des besoins et on
m'attaqué au début des questions sur
"vous dites qu'il y a
pas de précarité et que etc..."
j'insiste encore une fois : il y
a les faits et le ressenti des faits.
Ce qui compte, dans le bulletin de vote, c'est le ressenti
des faits, ce qui compte pour les physiciens, c'est les faits.
Donc, ce n'est pas parce que le ressenti
des faits est totalement distinct des faits
que pour autant les
faits ne sont pas valides.
À l'époque de la "France d'en
bas", j'avais fait l'expérience : je ne
connaissais personne
appartenant à la "France d'en haut"
donc toutes personnes considéraient que
la "France d'en bas" c'était lui plus tous
ceux qui sont en dessous.
Ça marche extrêmement bien ! Il y
a une autre boutade que je tiens mon
associé qui est la définition du
minimum vital, c'est quelque soit la
personne à qui vous posez la
question,  c'est "ce que gagne +10 %"
alors ce que je vous dis là c'est
de manière provocante, quelque chose que
Tocqueville avait extrêmement
bien expliqué, dans ses ouvrages, sur la
démocratie, c'est que la démocratie
nous rendra rouspéteur et perpétuellement
insatisfaits de notre sort, puisque
comme les chances sur la ligne de départ sont
censés être les mêmes pour tous,
si quelqu'un est devant vous à
la ligne d'arrivée = c'est pas juste!
Donc, le grand problème
c'est qu'il va falloir faire avec ça.
et en France 60.000 kilowattheures
par personne et par an, parce que c'est
ça qu'on consomme :
c'est 600 esclaves par personne!
L'espérance de vie à la naissance en
France, aujourd'hui 75 ans, l'espérance
de vie à la naissance en France, dans
les campagnes, il y a deux siècles : 25 ans !
Qui est pauvre ?
Donc, la question, elle est tout à fait centrale, en
terme de ressenti et d'équité, alors ça, vous avez 100% raison,
en termes de
réalité physique, je le redis,
même ce qu'on appelle "modestes"
devront prendre leur part à l'effort.
et la seule façon que je vois
que de leur faire prendre part à l'effort, c'est de
leur donner un boulot et de leurs donner des perspectives.
Sinon ça marchera
pas, sinon ça sera l'émeute.
et par contre, je pense que si ils ont
un boulot et une perspective et de la fierté
un boulot et une perspective et de la fierté,
on peut discuter.
Question de la fiscalité qui a
été posée aussi sur la taxe carbone.
La taxe carbone a un principe très
simple "je taxe plus l'énergie, je détaxe le
travail" c'est très simple : le
travail ne fait pas de changement climatique et
permettre de résoudre le chômage, le
carbone est importé et "fout en l'air" la balance
commerciale et il
"fout en l'air" le climat.
Je déplace la
fiscalité, c'est aussi simple que ça.
Il s'agit pas d'en faire quelque
chose de punitif il s'agit d'en faire quelque
chose qui guide.
qui guide alors.
C'est exactement, comme un
élève, vous lui dites pas que
en une semaine, après six ans, il
doit être capable de rentrer dans une
école d'ingénieur, il a 20
ans pour ça, c'est exactement pareil
pour un un métier plus généralement
là, c'est exactement pareil, il
s'agit de donner un cadre et une visibilité.
Il se trouve que mon boulot consiste,
à essayer de soutirer à des gens qui n'en
ont pas très envie, de
l'argent pour réfléchir à leur avenir,
ils s'appellent les
"affreux" industriels.
Que fait un "affreux" industriel ou un
"affreux" gestionnaire d'entreprise quand il
a à réfléchir, à l'avenir ?
Il regarde où sont les certitudes,
dans l'avenir qu'on lui propose...
et si, dans les certitudes, il n'y a
pas le fait que l'énergie qu'il consomme va
lui coûter de plus en plus
cher, il ne fait pas les investissements
correspondants ! Or
l'énergie, vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure,
c'est le "sang" de
systèmes qui sont extrêmement rigides
donc le problème énergétique et, ça a été dit
aussi, se résout par les investissements essentiellement.
C'est monstrueusement
capitalistique de faire de l'efficacité énergétique.
Monstrueusement capitalistique, il
faut changer les procédés industriels, il
faut changer les bâtiments, il faut
changer les infrastructures de transports,
changer les bateaux, il n'y a rien de
plus capitalistique que l'efficacité énergétique
donc si on ne donne rien... or
l'investissement vous avez besoin de
visibilité pour
avoir envie de les faire.
Donc si on ne donne pas un cadre
de visibilité à l'économie sur le prix
sur l'externalité
de l'inconvénient, et ça renvoie
à la finitude du monde, faut mettre ça
sous forme
externalités, dans l'économie,
mais ça ne fait pas un
projet de société : c'est un outil.
Si on ne donne pas un prix
aux externalités, dans lequel
l'industriel a de la visibilité
à ce moment
il reste assis sur sa chaise.
Il reste assis sur sa chaise et
c'est très exactement pareil pour les
particuliers. Regardez la manière
dont le différentiel essence/gazole a
déformé le parc
automobile en France en 30-40 ans
ça joue un rôle majeur à long terme,
ce genre de
signaux. À court terme, jamais,
à long terme, ça joue un rôle.
Alors, évidemment, c'est toute la
difficulté du métier que vous faites, vous êtes jugés,
sur les résultats à trois ans,
quand le remède, que vous proposez, va en
en produire à 30 ans.
C'est pour ça que je disais
si on ne plante pas dans la
population des consensus sur ce genre de
sujet qui dépasse
les clivages partisans,
on aura le bordel,
excusez-moi, on aura le bordel !
alors dans la dernière chose qui, là,
ne va pas faire plaisir, à notre ami Baupin
c'est la question du nucléaire.
Je pense que, si on veut que la
population achète une vision à long
terme et que si le milieu économique
achète une vision à long terme, via les médias
On ne peut pas être incohérent.
Donc on peut pas dire j'ai
hiérarchisé les nuisances comme ça, puis finalement
maintenant je vais les traiter comme
ça, donc ou bien on se dit la question de la
dépendance de l'économie
européenne aux combustibles fossiles et du
changement climatique, c'est supra
par rapport au nucléaire et alors on prend
tous ce qui permet
de virer les énergies fossiles !
Tout, nucléaire compris.
Ou bien, on dit
pour le moment, on a sorti un chiffre
d'un chapeau parce que 50% ça fait bien,
et puis 2025 ça fait bien, parce que, entre
nous, soit dit, c'est sorti d'un chapeau ces chiffres.
Et à ce moment
et à ce moment
Puis bon, Sarkozy en a sorti
d'autres, donc encore une fois on va,
on va équilibrer les débats
mais l'un comme l'autre
ont été victimes d'illusions,
ce n'est pas du
mensonge, c'est l'illusion.
C'est très différent, le
mensonge il y en a aussi mais là en
l'occurrence pour moi c'est
c'est pire que ça, quelque
part, c'est de l'illusion de l'illusion.
Et donc,
parce qu'il y a des grands hommes
d'état qui ont menti à des moments où
ils pensaient que c'était très utile
pour la population avec une vision de long terme
donc
je vais peut être vous choquer en vous
disant que le mensonge bien l'utilisé peut-être
qu'il y a des moments où c'est
très salutaire, mais là il s'agit pas de
mensonge, il s'agit des
illusions, c'est très très différents!
Donc si on dit dans cette affaire
que l'on se jette résolument dans le
fait
de mettre en place une société
qui sait fonctionner avec moins de
combustibles fossiles
D'abord je pense que le sujet du
nucléaire devient sujet secondaire,
il faut quand même savoir qu'en
Grande-Bretagne après la accident de Fukushima,
(Rires) l'acceptance
du nucléaire a augmenté
elle est plus forte aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne l'était avant Fukushima!
Chez les suédois, elle n'a pas changé,
donc arrêtons de nous regarder le
nombril, il n'y a pas que nous dans cette histoire
donc si on dit, on a vraiment,
en Iran, je ne suis pas partisan,
vraiment, mais encore une fois, il y a des tas de trucs
non, mais il a des tas de cas , je suis
très partisans d'avoir un couteau pour couper
un bifteck et pas partisan
d'avoir pour tuer quelqu'un donc la
question de savoir si un truc est
nécessairement blanc ou noir vous savez
très bien que c'est un faux débat.
Donc j'en reviens à ce que je disais : à partir du
moment elles ont dit c'est ça notre projet de long terme,
je pense que c'est si on arrive à
entraîner l'Europe, la France a encore
du poids
donc dans la
structuration du destin européen
je pense que si on arrive à
entraîner l'Europe dans une voie qui est
"on invente l'économie en 40 ans et
pas en une semaine"
on invente l'économie qui
permet d'avoir des aspirations sociales,
et d'avoir de l'espoir pour l'avenir,
avec de moins en moins de combustibles fossiles
je pense que c'est en faisant ça,
parce que nous sommes des animaux mimétiques,
qu'on a le maximum de chances
d'entraîner le reste du monde dans l'action
dit autrement, ça fait 20 ans qu'on se
regarde en "chiens de faïence", parce que
personne ne sait comment faire,
c'est les premiers, qui
font, qui emporteront le morceau.
Les premiers qui font. C'est une "prime à l'agresseur" ou
une "prime à l'assaillant", je ne sais pas comment il faut dire.
Mais c'est le premier qui
fait, qui emporte le morceau.
l'Europe a une raison excellente
pour faire qui n'a rien à voir et que le
climat, je le redis c'est que si on
reste sur la ligne de pente, en ce qui concerne
les combustibles fossiles,
on enchaînera des récessions en
étant complètement désemparés, face à ce qui
nous arrivera.
Voilà ce qui va se produire.
Donc le bazar, dans les
banlieues, c'est que le début,
si on reste sur la ligne de pente.
et encore une fois ce n'est pas critiquer,
le Président qu'on vient d'élire, de toute façon
on l'a pour cinq ans, on doit
bosser avec lui, ce n'est pas le sujet.
c'est de bien se rendre compte de
la marge de manœuvre et du terrain de
jeu qui est aujourd'hui le notre et
de ce qu'on a le droit de faire dans ce
terrain de jeu pour avoir de l'espoir
et de ce qui est vouée
à l'échec, d'entrée de jeu.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord et je suis
très content de l'avoir entendu, ce n'est pas
parce que
on s'est déjà parlé avant, avec la
remarque d'Edouard Phillipe, je pense que
ce truc là, cela doit vous
stimuler et pas du tout vous abattre.
Cela doit vous stimuler
et pas du tout vous abattre.
Par contre, je pense que
le temps presse, on l'a déjà dit
et je pense qu'il
est extrêmement urgent,
d'avoir quelque chose qui
commence à être un peu sérieux sur la manière
dont on fait un projet politique désirable
dans ce genre d'univers. Je pense que c'est urgent.
Moi, je veux bien vous aider!
Oui, dans les énergies renouvelables,
j'ai été un peu taquin une chose mais
qui correspond
encore une fois, aux faits.
Je vous donne un exemple.
à la suite du grenelle, on aurait
dit le truc intéressant c'est de déployer
les poêles à bois,
j'aurais dit : "Très bien"
On a dit : "on va investir dans
les panneaux solaires photovoltaïques"
c'est la dernière des conneries qu'il
fallait faire. Donc je ne suis pas contre les énergies
renouvelables je suis contre la méthode
sentimentale de gestion d'un sujet sérieux
à partir du moment où le sujet est majeur,
on ne le gère pas avec des méthodes sentimentales.
Moi, si j'ai un sujet majeur dans
ma boîte, je ne vais jamais gérer ça avec
des méthodes sentimentales
: sinon je suis sûr de couler.
Il y a un pays,
qui est remarquable en matière
d'énergies renouvelables qui s'appelle
la Suède
la Suède n'a quasiment pas de
combustibles fossiles dans son industrie lourde,
quasiment pas, je vous rappelle, soit
dit en passant, que la Suède consomme autant
d'électricité nucléaire
par personne que la France
Vous le saviez ça?
autant d'électricité nucléaire
par personne que la France, en Suède,
et ils ont, sauf erreur de ma part
une réputation parfaitement écolo, vu d'ici!
donc la Suède consomment
deux fois plus d'électricité
que la France par personne,
moitié hydraulique, moitié nucléaire
l'industrie lourde utilise
essentiellement de l'électricité décarbonée et du bois
ils ont une consommation de gaz et
de charbon en Suède qui est quasi-nulle
et la totalité du chauffage est
assuré avec des réseaux de chaleur au bois
mais ils ont 350.000
kilomètres carrés de pays
pour 9 millions d'habitants
couvert à 70% de forêts
et la clé du succès, pour les
énergies renouvelables, elle va être là.
et la clé du succès, pour les énergies
renouvelables, elle va être là. Toujours.
La clé du succès pour les énergies
renouvelables c'est beaucoup de montagnes,
et beaucoup d'espace pour
faire pousser quelque chose.
Sinon... compliqué!
Une des énergies renouvelables à
mon avis très intéressantes à regarder
pour les européens, c'est
ce qui se passe dans le désert
où il y a plein de soleil
...et pas beaucoup de monde à emmerder.
et au lieu de dépenser 100 ou 150 Mds dans de la CSPE pour déployer du photovoltaïque en France on aurait fait
un projet industriel, pour se mettre d'accord avec les marocains, les algériens ont du gaz donc ils s'en foutent,
et les tunisiens
et les libyens, aujourd'hui, on
aurait pris pied sur quelque chose qu'on était
sûr de donner du boulot aux
ouvriers français pour développer des
technologies qui seront
peut être extrêmement utile dans
toute la bande tropicale, à l'avenir.
Donc voilà, je ne suis pas du tout
contre les énergies renouvelables, je suis un
grand partisan des
énergies renouvelables gérées
avec des méthodes sérieuses.
Je suis désolé, c'est
beaucoup plus sérieux que le PV.
m
Un Ibertech (en Espagne)
serait plus intéressant qu'un Desertech.
Ecoutez,
aujourd'hui,
les espagnols aujourd'hui qui sont
en train de trouver la "potion économique"
pas très sympathiques, ils ont plein de
soleil dans le sud et, à mon avis, fallait
faire des choses intelligentes dans le
solaire à concentration avec les espagnols
c'est
bien mieux que de faire du PV en France.
Voilà, mieux que faire
du photovoltaïque en France.
Voilà ,donc la
question, c'est... pardon?
...l'éolien en France
n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt,
l'éolien a de l'intérêt dans les
pays qui ont des centrales à charbon et qui
souhaitent consommer
un peu moins de charbon.
Si vous commencez à avoir une
diffusion massive de l'éolien vous avez
besoin de moyens de stockage
derrière et le coût du mégawattheure
éolien stocké et restitué dans une STEP (retenue
d'eau réversible) que vous auriez créé pour l'occasion,
il se balade quelque part
entre 200 et 400 euros le MWh
alors c'est pas
nécessairement une mauvaise chose parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser une hausse des prix de l'énergie
moi je m'en fous
si c'est de la rente
redistribuée nationalement.
D'accord? je m'en fous.
C'est ça qu'il faut que ce soit.
Alors par ailleurs un autre truc, j'ai
pas eu le temps de vous présenter aujourd'hui
mais une autre règle de trois qui est disponible
sur mon site
montre et c'est peut-être le mot
de la fin, que quand vous déplacer une
énergie produite nationalement -
exemple : le nucléaire - vers une autre énergie
produite nationaleme
nt - exemple : l'éolien -
si vous payez les gens la même chose
dans les deux cas de figure, globalement
donc vous ne créez pas d'emplois.
C'est perturbant,
mais il y a une règle de
trois qui permet de le montrer.
Merci à Jean-Marc Jancovici,
pour son intervention et la
réponse à ces questions et ce débat nourri
et je l'espère,
fructueux. Merci beaucoup